the last word with lord cognito
and ibontis fresh on that friday man
first of all e how are you doing it's
just a regular day ain't got nobody
special right
no you know no tinfoil running around
the guest chat
no nothing nothing special no spookiness
no two games
i played through the medium and one that
one day yesterday so
the whole thing in one sitting uh okay
been enjoying some
some mix-ups but honestly still always
you know destiny has that special place
before i
before i say too much i got to give it
back no doubt
it's intro time it's your time
welcome to the last word episode number
one thirty four
one three four one thirty four i'm happy
and it's a glorious friday we're back in
front of the campfire for some more
lunar shooting discussion
i'm extremely excited about our special
guest so we're gonna get right into it
want to introduce a lord whose
combination of pure positivity and
consistency within a destiny community
is truly a sight to behold whether it be
his informative how-to videos or his
multi-platform race stream help
all done with the most infectious smile
in the game
introducing the software developer slash
creator and host of the cb grade youtube
and twitch channels
the lord of tin foil hacks
and voice boy bar so cold even the real
aries moon was bumping to that beyond
light
wow live from va
and making his glorious return at the
campfire of the last
word my man lord cb
gray how we doing sir i'm speechless
i don't even know how to say nothing i'm
good
now i'm good i'm i'm real real real real
good and i'm happy to be back and it's
it's feeling like home already i'm happy
oh yeah y'all i missed you all
right i missed you man we are here we
had a great show we had a great show it
was always a pleasure to have you in
here man i literally know how we can
continue after that intro
no we just got to shut it down
no i open the discord like dm to you
guys that said and i was like make a new
one
you have one from nine months ago i was
like it's been a minute
so has it it's been nine that's how long
i think that's what it said so i was
like i have no idea how exact but
ballpark about nine months man so thank
you for coming back i know we had a
blast last time
definitely uh looking forward to it sir
yeah
i'm hyped i'm excited too and before we
get into anything
especially after the way they just came
in on me just know that these two
134 episodes doing anything 134 times
is absolutely insane like seriously like
the amount of work that these two put in
like for this and then what they do
individually because
mr e is putting together crazy crazy
guys every two seconds every two seconds
i see he's like
i don't know when he's sleeping or doing
anything and then this man mr lord
the podcast also they put together on
the youtube side of things
thank you if you all ever checked it out
i would get it in chat because
that's that's my weekend thing i'm in
there working every time i'm lurking and
working
usually yeah i can't even start it
without telling y'all how
how dope these two are so thank you now
we can get it
but i can't i couldn't even i couldn't
let it go any further i couldn't live
any further hold on i got it i got to
wipe the tears out
we made it man seriously we have been
blessed
by the by the tin foil god over
so yeah so um started a new project at
work
um we're building an application for the
air force
so i'm a tech lead on this project now
we're working a 12-month project
uh so uh i know last time we talked down
i think that was going on so yeah that
started in october
um right around when uh right before um
beyond light
dropping all right so we got that going
on at work and then uh
outside of that you know saying well
stable still streaming on youtube we
stream on twitch we get the videos uh we
help out where we can we hang out we
just laugh
and run in circles and act to fool and
you know we just we just do we just do
what we do but it's
it's been it's been good man it's been
good um i'm alive man so you know i
can't
exactly this man over here streams on
which what's the order is it twitch
no the orders so after i finish i try to
get off work around like seven
and then i'll try to be streaming on
youtube by around 7 30 eight and then
i'll do from about eight to 11 on
youtube then
we'll jump to twitch until maybe like
one or two in the morning man wow wow
so sleep is just a sporadic thing that
you get every so often
i don't even know they're worried
[Laughter]
there is caffeine in his there's blood
in his caffeine stream i think at this
point
ice water ice water he's got ice running
through his veins that's what it is
though
so you know
he told me i was like nah i was like get
out of here no i know
i i'm still i still know if i believe it
i got the receipts aka driver's license
birth certificate and everything else
teach me your secrets just teach me the
weights
just luck i think and then staying
inside and playing video games so you
don't see the sun
so yeah you can relate
yeah it definitely would affect it
so how has it been going for like how
did you decide to go
from doing both like what made you say
like hey
i'm doing this thing on youtube awesome
channel i want to try twitch or i want
to try streaming
and then how did you like also ask like
your collection of followers and
everybody would be like hey can you guys
go to a different website and watch me
over here
because like it's working but i'm kind
of curious the secret to your sauce as
well
well well transferring platforms and
anything is definitely you know it is
hard
um to you know i guess be able to
transfer over and kind of
have the same kind of dynamic that you
have on another platform
um but what made me i guess decide to
start um there's kind of two big reasons
i'd say the first was just one to
continue to
to do more and to be able to help out
more and to be able to kind of spread
out the reach of what we do and to be
able to kind of
i think bridge the gap and to be able to
you know help on the side of things that
we have
with the youtube side but then try to
also uh
continue on with that uh kind of same
note on uh the twitch side as well
because i felt like we were we i really
was happy what we were doing on the
youtube side but i knew there's still a
lot going on the twitch side as well i
just felt like we could
continue to kind of spread our roots and
try to you know do our part more
over there as well that was like one big
reason but then the other
two was so i've been with youtube
streaming since the beta i remember when
youtube um sent me um the streams the
streams like not youtube since
youtube stream since the beta so i can
remember when they like uh
actually emailed me like talking about
the beta and like and i tried it out
then but so i've been with youtube for a
while for streaming
and i've been happy to see the platform
kind of evolve and see all the features
that have come
but um it still is a while ago and
there's some features that i definitely
wanted to also be able to
i'd say use um when it came to streaming
as well one of the bigger things being
raiding
um i really love seeing a lot of the
other creators that we have in our
community as well and being able to you
know all kind of
work collectively together and uh and
kind of also
provide an environment hopefully where
people can feel empowered to start and
kind of do whatever they want in life
um but i didn't like that uh well
youtube i could never rate anybody and i
could never you know we could never
just extend our we can never extend our
community anywhere else
without like you know just typing a link
in the chat you know right um so
i i really was always kind of intrigued
by that and
and i wanted to you know be able to do
that as well so i thought that was
really cool
how to get it to work um ask nicely just
think thank you thank everybody that um
you know is here at sydney watching me
now and just in general that's ever
supported me um
i i don't know i i'm grateful for it uh
and that people do stick around for both
i mean i think it's asking a lot to be
able to be like all right you're already
watching here now
you know download another app or go
somewhere else where you might not you
know enjoy the app as much or like
whatever the case may be
um so i don't know i i'm not sure
exactly but
in terms of what we do though i'll
usually finish the stream and then you
know we'll
collectively just decide that all right
now we're headed to twitch and so we'll
you know
get the link out for the twitch and then
i'll usually start streaming on twitch
like about
within probably 30 seconds after i stop
the youtube yeah one
so it's a very seamless transition but i
mean
to talk about why it works it's all uh
everybody that's
you know part of our community because
i'm surprised that it does i'm just
grateful
so i mean yeah yeah it's uh it
definitely couldn't with just me
so absolutely you might be the glue
that's holding it together but yeah it's
like i don't think
any content creators anybody without
their community
and yeah yeah like everybody who shows
up for the podcast the streams iron lord
podcast yours on both ends of the table
it's it's always the people in the chat
that remind you yeah thank you
and it and it's like the stories that
say hey thanks for being here i had a
rough day wanted to come say hi and it's
like
you know what those rare moments when
it's like i may have five people in here
but somebody needed that like
getaway for a second and it's like if
i'm in a point where i'm lucky enough to
help
some person that way i can talk to two
people all night if i'm helping one
that's
and yeah it's those are the rare moments
and honestly like
you are very very humble ultra humble
but like what you do your positivity
your vibes and your stream
it's very easy to see why you have the
following that you do yeah
absolutely thanks so much absolutely
brother what you're doing is
truly unique and it's just cool it's
cool to see because like
like you were saying like you know what
he was saying like to transition from
one platform to another
usually people come up with all the
excuses in the world or just at the end
of the day even it's not excuses just
people are comfortable in their platform
like you said or sometimes they just
don't want to open up another app or
whatever
so to get people that there or and also
another
audience to also follow is really unique
and cool and again it's a testament
to you the team and the content you're
doing there's a lot of positivity
and we need to see more of it you know i
mean so that's why you know we got to
celebrate your here
i appreciate it man that means a lot
especially here from y'all because you
like i say y'all the goat so i
appreciate it i appreciate the kind
words it means a lot
um and yeah i'm excited to keep that
going too man it's been something that's
been really cool
because one of the the coolest things
about it
has really been meeting so many new
faces too when going to a different
platform because it is a whole
new like um you know group of people and
there's more
there's more people to meet there's more
people that you know help there's more
ultimately friendships to make
yeah you know so that's been the coolest
thing i mean i started
doing the twitch uh like streams on top
of the youtube ones it'll be um
a year sometime in uh february that's
when i when that's when i got going with
with uh
twitch um so it's been a really cool
experience like i'm still learning
on like day by day with it but it's it's
been it's been really cool
yeah shout out to you guys i was just
gonna say it's like the more we
the more you try and do the more you
realize you don't know so i feel like
it's always an uphill battle
oh yeah yeah absolutely absolutely i had
a question before
we gotta talk about this bus boys didn't
talk about that last time oh yeah we
didn't get to talk about that that is
true
that is true you know i saw the joy drop
but i said oh
okay so so these are the brothers like
let's go
break this down this three-man group
what's going on
so that stems all the way back to
college so back when i was like um
i guess i was like 21 yeah i was 21 i um
good
so um not back there but you know a
little bit of time ago
did i get that right yeah a little bit
of time ago
without when i was uh in college so two
of my best friends
uh tyler and quan um two people that you
know those like
my brothers like tyler i've known like
forever and then
quan just same deal like just just
really really like those like
like two of my brothers and um we spent
you know
just i don't know they were like some of
my rocks in college because i was
between computer science kicking my butt
and a lot of other factors it was it was
a real struggle so like
they they really like helped me a lot
when i was in school and just like
they're always there for me and you know
vice versa and so we just we just came
up and
we always uh it was funny we used to um
at my college uh jmu it's such a funny
time
my cup but because jmu um we used the
loot
to actually talk about how the boss
thing came um yeah
there was it was always coke products in
the um the vending machines and then
one year randomly we switched to pepsi
and so then within these pepsi machines
there's
these
vast water bottles in the vending
machines like oh that's interesting i've
never seen this brand before so
you know we buy them up we just and we
start just like carrying around just
drinking when we go out and play
basketball
um at the gym a lot and then somebody
one day just called us
y'all
next thing you know i mean um one day
uh we uh in my
uh apartment we just like we just we're
sitting around this we heard this beat
but i don't even know why we were
listening to beasts but we just heard
this beat
and then next thing you know we fell in
love with it and then we recorded this
song in my closet
it like and you know it came out
really well and i was like yeah that's
kind of that was kind of cool
so you know so we kind of like we
started making more music i
fiddled around with music before like it
wasn't the first time i ever made a song
but it was like the first time i really
made a song
yeah and so and so we started making
more and more music whilst
in college uh some of the things that um
like
might be on the page that you looked at
um and then
um when i got closer to graduating
like we actually like went into the
studio a couple times like actually and
then that's when i started like
really like learning a little bit more
about how to like really really make a
song
and so then um started making more music
with uh
them and then a few songs myself and
then
when it came to the channel um uh back
when
kate 6 and forsaken and yeah
and that's when i we had a song called
space and i was like yo i kind of want
to make this like
like uh tribute to and so i made
a song and had a video in the background
of kade and put together this whole like
you know like kind of custom k-6 tribute
with the song in the background and i
didn't expect anybody to watch it
yeah because there's like it's you know
i make guides and you know stream and i
don't make
music though for the channel so you know
it's kind of weird when you kind of go
into a different realm you don't really
think it's gonna be accepted or anything
right but i put it out and and it was
like overwhelming like the amount of
support
um that that song got in and it's next
thing you know i was like you know what
i'm gonna put it as the intro of my
youtube videos
so that that's awesome snippet at the
beginning is that every single one of my
youtube videos and then
people like well when's the next one i
was like next one
so i was like okay so we made a couple
more and i'd say
the biggest like like outside of like
the community response because it's one
of the coolest things to
make something that didn't exist and
have people really enjoy it i think
that's one of the most like fulfilling
things it's really cool when the people
like say some of the lyrics or something
i'm like wow that's that's really cool
that's fine
at one point i remember i was sitting in
the car and i that popped up in my brain
and now like people are saying it's like
that's that's pretty cool
um but then i remember when we put out
moons haunted after shadow keep mm-hmm
and then i'm in i'm sitting i i was
sitting um at work
and then i get a uh tweet notification i
look it's morla
eris dude and i was like i saw that i
was like
what i was like and it's like talking
about she loved the song then next thing
i know i get another notification
and she she messaged me and and was
talking my son
won't stop singing your song that's it
and i was like
all right and so next thing you know i
had a full conversation with more
lamora's amazing by the way like
when we were at guardian con yeah did
you meet her too when we were
yeah i did i saw you staying in the line
yeah so we both when he and i were at
gcx uh we both were in line um but yeah
so
met her there but didn't know her at the
time but um
yeah when i saw that and then we had a
great conversation and she's just
like i tell you i mean she's one of the
most amazing like voice actors there is
but she is also like
one of the most amazing people she's
really really cool and then so
we dropped the song uh for beyond light
that you uh
were just referencing and once again she
said something again uh
she's like legendary you know so having
her like making a song that's about
that destiny related and then to have it
acknowledged it all was like
that that really made me feel good too
so between the community supporting that
and then
like eris uh morla like that that's
that's kind of how that came out though
that's how it came to be and so now i
try to
stick to about one destiny song a year
for each big release so i'm gonna try to
do something for
for a witch queen with uh my best friend
tyler but yeah none of that would be
possible without my friends too with
their song i'm without let me excuse me
with
with uh everything they put into those
because uh
they're the ones with the talent i mean
i i i enjoy it but like
they they really um they really got it
i'm just kind of just there for the ride
salute to the voice boys fantastic man
big story brothers great stories that's
one of those like tweets where you're
like okay you could just push me over
with a feather right now yeah yeah yeah
yeah i was like
some of the best moments as a content
creator for sure you get that
acknowledgement from your peers
awesome that's well that's okay now the
show's
over because like that's like such a
high point seriously though so
um honestly one little random thing i
did want to ask you though is there is
there
going back to what we were talking about
before i was just what was sticking my
head
youtube versus twitch for streaming is
there anything you
notice different like what's the main
differences that you see between the two
because you're one of those few that's
like yeah
there's tons of differences to be honest
yeah there's tons like there's a lot of
differences to be honest
like um and i can kind of break it down
but i'll kind of stay
like i guess at relatively high level
just for the interest of like not
talking about it all day because
there's a lot to it but in terms of like
getting started it's easier to start on
twitch
like 100 in terms of the barrier to
entry
in terms of that that first milestone
that you hit for streaming
on on twitch is affiliation on youtube
is uh monetization monetization are the
two things like in terms of like
i'd say like one of like you know the
like i call them feature goals because
like there's plenty of goals just you
know having
friends and people to talk to and chat
those are like those goals but i'm
talking about the goals for like i guess
like the twitch feature that you
eventually get is
affiliate and then the youtube feature
is like uh monetization right
um the barrier that they added for
youtube monetization is
extremely hard um a thousand subscribers
four thousand hours of watch time
before you can and you can't have
membership if you
don't have monetization so you can have
emotes if you don't have monetization
those are some of the the basic things
are really fun like you know about
having a couple emotes that you know
people can uh use or seen a tenfold hat
in the chat or
you know all of the advanced cheetahs
but but yeah that that can be really i
would say deterring
and and really um i'd say like um
just it it can kind of discourage you if
you know it
like when it's like man like that's
really hard because even let's i know a
couple of people who
they hit the thousand subscribers but
then it's like but i'm still like what
are your suggestions for like hitting
the four thousand hours of watch time
that's a lot of watch time yeah
yeah so that's a whole lot of watch time
oh yeah and that barrier didn't come
when i first started
um that barrier came yeah i guess for
yeah
as well yeah exactly when we were
because how long ago did you start e
god is it four plus now yeah same same
for me yeah starting in 2016. yeah 2016
in june so
maybe five years in june but yeah back
when
you know i started the channel i was
just like do you want to monetize and i
guess i was like
sure and you know just hit a button you
know and you put in the information and
then next thing you know
that's a thing but it's not a thing
anymore so
basic like first step for that
affiliation
that monetization like the most glaring
difference
is it's a a lot harder on on youtube to
get started
yeah that that part is um like i'd say
um like kind of blatantly obvious
um that piece and then then the next
piece is um
i'd say the connect
ability i don't really that's not even a
word but i'll explain it why like i'm
saying connectability
but like on youtube especially if like
you know i'm really happy with like
the youtube stream inside the community
that we've kind of at least on our end
kind of uh
started to develop where there are like
we have a couple of like different uh
youtube streamers that are doing amazing
like like versace that's in here
i see but yeah but um
so i mean it's great so to see a few
other youtube streamers around but if
you don't really know any other
streamers you can feel very alone
especially when i first got started so
when i first started streaming on the
platform back when
i think i still have the the app on my
phone as a souvenir
let me see if i can find that youtube
gaming app um yep
yep here it is right here so youtube
gaming it's gonna do nothing it's not
gonna load i just never
uh removed it because it's part of where
i stopped i started and
it just reminds me of you know back in
the day um so i never deleted the app
because you can't
uh download it again yeah it's not it's
not available
forever now too no trade-ins yeah
um but but so with that being said um
it was it felt very isolated back then
especially then
because um it was just starting
there was a lot of things that a lot of
people don't even know about how that
used to work where
if you gained any subscribers back um
when youtube gaming was a thing on the
app right those subscribers wouldn't get
notified for any videos
and then people on videos
it was almost like you're building like
so now they've gotten better with that
but back then especially it was it was
like a separate entity almost yeah
exactly right and so um the way that
that
they they kind of got they did away at
the app obviously as you saw
um but even still there's no just
directory
you know where you can just like they're
kind they're trying but it's not just
like a very
easy way of here's destiny here's this
here's that let me click here's the
streamer streaming
they still have a long way to go to get
that directory there where you feel like
there's other streamers you can easily
find
yeah it's still it still feels very hard
a lot of times to find people
um where on twitch that very easily
navigateable
like i'm not saying it still takes a
while to scroll and find everybody but
very easy navigable where you can find
people streaming the game
in seconds right yep now is that going
to be every single person no
but you can find people very easily
another another benefit to twitch
my favorite um youtube side of things
what's what's great about you because
there's there's there's pros and cons to
both
discoverability once you get going once
you get going though that's the site
yeah
preferences display ability once you get
going
when act activities happen when certain
events happen
when anything is actually happening um
youtube can be very powerful in the
sense of they're recommended
yeah so algorithm would recommend there
there can be times where
you end up with a viewing that would be
more or less impossible to get on twitch
just because just take for example um
thorn let's just use just a random one
thorne comes out
every everybody obviously is watching
who they watch on twitch and that's
that's a thing
um and then on youtube everybody's
searching how do i get thorn how do i
get thrown how do i get through how do i
get thorn
no videos exist yet because everybody's
out kidding thorn right if you're
streaming on
youtube while that's happening and
people are searching how do i get thor
how do i get thorn if there's no videos
that exist what do you think pops up
yep you that's what yes or anybody
that's doing it yeah
and so that's like one of the the main
ways that like i mean
in terms of discovery ability especially
during certain moments
that um can really uh that youtube
definitely
a hundred percent has a as a very clear
engine especially if you're not
i'd say um you know just i don't know
you
if you're just getting going it's it's a
little bit easier in that department
um there there are other differences i
mean the
50 50 split on twitch versus the 70 30
on youtube
um that not a lot of people know about
but yeah it is a lot uh the youtube i
think tries to entice people a little
bit more with that as well
um and then lastly uh twitch is just on
us just a lot further on the features
like i said the raids
raids are just so so much better um
the uh the different ways of making
people feel connected
the channel points the different ways of
you know engaging people and just having
fun you know
even if it's just somebody just telling
you know you to hydrate or to stretch
or to do whatever or to use their
channels don't give them ideas that's
what i'm gonna say
oh yeah oh yeah
to make me put on a tin foil hat or some
sunglasses or whatever the case may be
um those those things are are really
really cool and and
and youtube still like they're getting
there but um those things are
already there and very solidified on
twitch um as well as um
gifting subs too and people that that's
i think going to be something that
until youtube gets that part i don't see
them getting a lot of
gigantic people to like make the jump at
least personally
but um hopefully i broke that down at
least decently oh you killed that
you absolutely crushed it and that's one
of those two is the recommended is a
thing for youtube and you never
quite know when the lights gonna be
shining on you
brightly yeah and my biggest video had
that happen
one time and then it's like but also
it's like it's the other side is like
you can have that
awesome peak but then youtube can also
have lulls as well depending on
consistency and stuff like that because
there's a lot of big creators if you're
trying to get
in there's a lot of bigger like the
twitch directory is deep
the youtube directory for videos just as
like just as if not more so
agree it's you can be
talented you can be likable you can be
skilled you can be funny
there's going to be generally luck in
that equation as well somewhere 100
percent
like being and being ready when the luck
comes your way
yeah that's the biggest is the biggest
part is just continuing to be there
until you get lucky
yeah absolutely so yeah it's a
definitely a combination
yeah i mean some of the stories you i
mean some of the references you were
making
definitely reminded me you know because
we started seriously
2018 i would say
seriously 2016 we started we judged the
channel but
but i remember i remember like man we
got to get a thousand like
i remember just trying to get 1 000 like
on youtube just just you know
so you could have monetized you can have
the emotes you can even super chat
because once that happens it really
creates that connection
with the audience exactly because you
know it's not just monetization but it's
really cool to be able to have that
aspect because there's not
any real other youtube aspects to engage
yet right so that the emotes are a
really cool thing oh yeah absolutely
so and to the twitch point you said um
yeah like one thing that's so cool about
it like you said the feature to read
another person's stream it's that
interconnected thing so it's like
actually when someone else in the
community sees you on they can do vice
it's just spreading the law
and communities kind of mix it so i do
see where you're going with that yeah
and um yeah like i said again
testament to you to be able to do both
that is a very
rare thing and and you understanding
this stuff and and being
providing the content you're providing
as well as people you know
gravitating towards you so that's dope
man thanks bro
well obviously we do talk about looter
shooters and things like that and come
february 25th we are going to talk about
a different game
on this podcast as well called out
raiders
cause yeah that one honestly looks like
a ton of fun honestly they're seeing
that
the biggest thing i can say before we
get into destiny is just because they've
been dropping
tweets about armor sets and stuff this
week for one they have armor sets i'm
like
thank you i've been asking for a minute
but honestly i will say like the
the gaming landscape right now has had
its ups and downs to say the very least
your avengers your cyberpunks your goods
your bads like
yeah they're going everywhere they're
one of the rare like
somewhat deep longer rpgs with like a
bespoke in game but the fact that like
whether you believe anything anybody
tells you about it there is a free demo
on february 25th
to try it and your progress goes into
the full game so you're like
well i got my character up to level
eight you literally can jump in and go
from there when the game goes live and
that i think is like one of those things
why
i think my interest has peaked is there
one have the confidence to do it
and then two just the more i see about
it the more
just honestly to give it a shot because
if nothing else you get a free chance
and that's
rare and i just wanted to see what you
guys were thinking about out writers if
you'd seen it or if you even care
so i i did see a trailer um
and i heard about the demo and so i i
think i'm gonna pop in and just and see
what it's about i don't have like any
strong
opinions either way yet i did think it
was funny that um i don't know why i was
having weird deja vu about um
jumping into a new lunar shooter in
february in february
okay okay we're at deja vu why is this
thing for me i'm gonna jump into another
game in february wouldn't i do this
before and then
i think you know what i'm talking about
uh with the good old anthem back in the
day
i've seen the trailer and i think it's
at least worth you know like playing
around
running around seeing what it's about
yeah the same thing i mean for me it's
like um
you know people can fly you know i i
know about them a bit
and um like what i like is that they
they're not
the mistake i feel a lot of these lunar
shooters do is they see the formula
destiny has they're like
we're gonna be the destiny killer we're
gonna do this and it's live service and
we're
offering just as much as they are and
it's like no no they are creating their
own lane they're not promoting they're
specifically saying look there's not
gonna be any
micro transaction kind of stuff and you
know it's gonna be pve only like they're
carving their specific lane and setting
expectations correctly
and i like when they do that so that to
me is a good start
um look i i i i've ever told spock to e
about this but
i keep forgetting i always been meaning
to bring up now bring it up today is
that
we need destiny needs to be pushed it
doesn't
need to be almost because it's always
better
it's always better and at the end of the
day it's the de facto
king it has survived all these winters
and summers
you know even as angry as we are you
know some of the computers now you know
we're still playing we still got the
hours
and i'll never forget you know i always
salute division one
you know i remember when division one
dropped during like a very
cold stage of of destiny and i was i
would say that was like
before taking king after house of wolves
i think i want to say it was like
20 like 15 or 14 i remember like
yeah probably would have been the house
of wolves or that big break
right there was no raid trials was there
but it was nowhere trials just keeping
it alive kind of barely
yeah and then you know it was a while
for that drought before tayden king
actually came
right it was and it was people were
concerned you know and at that time here
comes this young aggressive
you know new luna shooter in new york
city
snowdrop engine looking good and people
pulled away and i remember the destiny
community my friends were like we're
over here now how about you traitors
i was about this at first i was like
thirsty's gonna come back i was so
stubborn i was still playing destiny
wasn't that good
at the time but i would still love the
game so much i was like it's gonna be
better it's gonna be bad
you know that's that kind of thing but
now the reality and then the drop taking
game
yep you know what happened competition
you already know what happened there but
um yeah long story short just like
competition is always good and uh i want
to see
outriders just as a pallet clan see what
they got to offer
see and again if they offer some new
things and get a little buzz
again maybe force bungie's hand a little
bit just to uh hey
pay attention to what these guys are
doing a little bit yeah it's just nice
to see as you said pve alone only
there's not the pvp balance sandbox so
you see stuff that looks kind of broken
it's like guess what you're fighting
enemies doesn't matter it can be broken
um yeah the the animations on like every
some people say it looks like a little
too gritty i'm like
you know you're gonna have your
dystopian worlds and things like that
and destiny does have a point where sure
you're gonna have your kind of beat up
edcs and ruins but you've also got like
the vibrancy of the leviathan which is
unique
and destiny is really cool for amazing
environments
but i will say like as you said they've
stated very clearly
there's a start and an end to this thing
yeah there is a
but they're like hey we're going voice
acted story 40 hours 40 ish hour
campaigns like one number i heard once
once you finish the campaign there's
like 14 to 15
like new in-game levels to grind for
like time challenges and higher gear
and levels they've got the world tier
system but like they've got those
options you've got skill trees that are
like deep enough
that you have to kind of commit to get
to the end of one and you might be able
to get some other stuff but you can't
just like
i want everything no no you're gonna
have to like and i miss skill trees from
d1 for example like kind of
picking yeah that's something that i do
still i'm still hoping they might
re-adopt and it's like that no seriously
like and that's the
the rpg side i wish bundy would lean
into because you're gonna have
your stats in your armor and your loot
it's gonna be there but you've also got
like skills and other things that you're
gonna have i don't know if it's quite
like diablo where you're like i want
vitality and i want other stuff but i
was like
just just lean keep leaning into the rpg
if they want it to again i'm still
curious what they're gonna do with armor
i've harped out on about that for
episodes i don't know what's gonna
happen but
they want to make armor not just a
replacement annual stat holder
that holds your mods like they've said
they want to change that i'm very
curious where they take that and seeing
something like outriders with
armor sets and bonuses that come from
those and the way they're taking them
like you earn a uni like could the way
that works for them like you earn a
legendary or
a high-tier piece of armor they have
like mods that come with them
you can get another one of those pull
that mod out and put it in something
else
combine like two different abilities
together mm-hmm
like that well customization could be
dope yeah so just seeing all the
different varieties that
that has is just like i'd love to see
destiny again the balance is tough i
know like the pve pvp balance but it's
just exciting to see
something i think that you can play the
whole package when you buy it there's no
dlc no other stuff nothing else planned
so overall i'm just kind of like i'm as
i said on twitter it's like i'm leaning
optimistic now at this point
get my hands on the free demo and see
how it feels so no doubt no doubt
no doubt man i'm with you man like i
said the other day gotta check it out
see what's going on
um you know looks promising and gotta i
gotta say what's the release date what's
our release date look look i think the
25th right 25th is the demo and then
another
first is the game yeah okay okay okay
yeah
it's not april fools to my understanding
that's what happened i hope it doesn't
flop on launch day because then
everybody you know the media
yeah yeah if if it flows on april fools
that'd just be
honestly they'll just shift the day just
like it doesn't get off the check
yeah but you know you know yeah honestly
like the demo until probably beforehand
so we'll know but
yeah i was gonna ask um cb so what have
you been up to in the world of destiny
since that's obviously our big topic of
discussion tonight before we actually
get into the juiciness of the week
in destiny honestly for the most part
outside of
you know when new stuff comes in playing
it same deal still just been helping
just kind of shifted some of the
things that i used to do a little bit
more focus on you guys knows really big
i loved uh and
really big and to whisper and outbreak
and yeah and some of those secret
missions so
i've been happy that hawkmoon's been
back it's kind of scratching that it's
been scratching that itch a little bit
so it's been um mainly for me um
raid hope dungeon help exotic help and
then
dipping our feet into trellis on friday
but um
outside of that that's been the biggest
parts i haven't been
i'd say super engaged in the season this
season right
like you know when new stuff comes
obviously there like to do it
but then like after that then i usually
end up back in uh we've been doing a lot
of last wish
i've ever really like i've been enjoying
seeing a lot of uh
newer people get their 1ks to drop and
seeing those reactions again
uh that's doing some deep stone crypt in
the same deal um
you know i was feeling about deep stone
crips i haven't got a chance to talk to
you about rage because i like to talk
great
i i liked it for his farm ability like
that was one of the biggest pieces for
me that i really enjoyed
um i love how you can just fly through
it and then i love how it's also
um uh just one that
even when i finish it i don't feel very
burned
yeah like i i i i enjoy going through it
multiple times
favorite encounter only caveat for me is
i actually enjoyed contest mode so much
that it made me sad yeah
i couldn't stop that i really really
wish
and with that one especially because i
feel like they had the right level
yeah why not yeah at least yeah i feel
like they had the right level on that
one where
you know some of them with contests felt
like i mean it was like
crazy crazy but that one i felt like
they actually had like a really really
right yeah
good point where i think the hardcore
people liked it and even people who
maybe aren't hardcore i think also would
have would have liked
that challenge of keep pushing until you
can get that contest mode done
um type thing so overall i did like it i
thought the weapons were cool i thought
the
system at the end of being able to get
uh weapons and kind of tuning
tuning and tuning your lures that's the
machine machine vibes
exactly yeah and then you can get the
spoils of war at the end
spoilers like they did a lot of things
right
yeah they did they did a lot of things
right um so
i overall i'm a fan yes um of it
and so what does that fall on is it in
your is it
nearly where is it for your listing
early
in the beginning feelings d2 or at all
overall where is it at
raw where is it in the pantheon
yeah it's hard right it's all i know i
was thinking about it too
well you know it it it's not touching
wrath boulder uh
or king's full for me
yeah is it out there it might be
man it doesn't have a hard mode though
it might be
top five for me to be honest maybe but
it's harder for me so i definitely
because the top four i think are last
wish king's fall
access and uh vaulted glass um
the d-1 yeah
i think that i might put it there and
then because you know i'm weird i love
spire and for my own
not actual like uh you know rational
thing i might throw my spire in there
with no rationale
that's right no no no even reasons to
put it there i realize that's not better
but um that's my read i miss you shout
out to you bro
shout out to you and that right right
dick dude
yeah remember like right before the sun
setting happened that's the last thing
we were doing help streams while we were
doing inspires it's like man
checking on my dogs
what about you where do you have it
where does it fall for you well first
before i get the ranking i wanted to um
say
as far as the encounters i really love
this ray you know i haven't rated this
much in a while
but i know because i'm rating this much
i enjoyed it i'm completely with you
it's great but i can't go top three
those four that we do
those four are just solidified right now
right yeah
so but it is fun you know what
here's where it definitely top five for
me okay
is like you said farm ability yeah
um i feel like i said the weapons are
amazing these new perks the
recombination or whatever
yeah destruction yeah reconstruction
right yeah is it tomorrow you know what
i'm saying the farmer and the last thing
i don't think he gets enough credit even
though um
i was a little not that the boss fight
is dope i was just a little bit probably
it was a little bit of a letdown
because they were it was like this right
it was like this the whole time
and maybe even and then you get the
lullaby you look outside and then it's
like this
and then the next encounter like it's
all crazy i'm still going up
and then i get them like annex bro yeah
same thing like it is
once you hit outside and the deep stone
lullaby kick
yeah i was like this might be this we
going in the goat territory yeah
yeah then i love like you said i
love the frenetic nature of the ship
about the crash and the bombs and the
the music hit and you you're
right who got this oppressor like that
music it's
pure chaos and i love it then the boss
have them
and it's not that the encounter is whack
and then mcat it's just
i didn't want to see you like i wanted
to see clovis
like i would be real i was a cl i was
like where's clovis at
so i was like damn you know what's
happening if you guys even
i just don't think he held as much
weight as like like think about when you
first see orcs and that man is like
rage what they already like
videos yeah the first time you drop down
the circle and see
riven preach yeah or or um
even on a smaller scale atheon and
maybe and maybe it's just because he's
been used a couple of times maybe maybe
he wouldn't feel like he was epic if he
wasn't but i still
even with like trying to have like
unbiased blind eyes that have never seen
tanix before
right i still don't think he would have
hit his heart for me i would agree at
least
he's a fallen he's a fallen kind of kell
but we
we see those in story missions we see
him over here and there and it's just
like
he just you know he was had his little
floaty robot bottom half
and then he's kind of roaming around the
other part before but it's like that's i
mean
even atrax was a step up because you're
like this is an
exo fall and you're like he actually
looks kind of cool yes
i'm with you it's like take that to the
next level where it's like
i want to see either bigger or just
something about
like if you're going to put tannic's
name on it put it like mechanical like i
want to see like godzilla tannics like i
don't care just like
something ridiculous is all so
is one of the dopest cloaks in all of
history he made him play hunter so this
is no hate
on tanex because i played hunter
for that man i wanted i wanted to wear
that cloak of tannics now speaking of
that i know we're gonna get into
you know all the destiny stuff here and
or the that you know what we want in the
future in a second but
strike armor please can
please please please oh my titan
shield brothers gauntlets please i'm
gonna get the
the scion advocated for it every single
day i just it'd be such
a lightweight like low lift
high reward i think for a change they
could put in
it's just a couple pieces on each
character sprinkle them into the strikes
and you got me in there i don't know
yeah
about the viability of playlists here in
a little bit but no
yeah the dark blade helm
has been still one of my favorite pieces
of arm in the game
i'm literally wearing his dude the
dude's head as a hat
yes
well uh it's been a few spicy weeks in
the world of destiny 2 to say the least
and if you follow the destiny twitter
maybe you muted half of it i don't know
um but either way it's been interesting
so
keep your wits about you block the
people you need to
follow take everything with a grain of
salt however you got to do it but
of course another swab happened and of
course twitter's bungie ex but or
destiny's twitter exploded
couple things one obviously hawkmoon
missions have been back
harbinger has been doing its thing kind
of cool some people are finishing it
getting their ships
overall as you said it's nice to have
one of those missions back especially as
we just lost both of the two that kind
of made
secret mission runs for content creators
and helps and stuff like that a really
cool thing it's nice to have one back
i took my brother and his son through it
which was really cool for the three of
us to go through so
nice that was fun um and it even
actually this week
different mechanics in this different
path too yeah
different pathing and i was like so you
go
as soon as i took him i was like so
you're gonna hold on
those that was the force field thing
yeah
okay different feather locations i was
like
all right well done way to mix it up so
there's just a little variation
i dug that yeah i did too
season of the redacted trailer goes live
february
2nd yes tuesday reset probably at like
nine eight
yeah what do you guys want to see from
this and
what what are your hopes what do you
don't want to see what do you do
guest of honor of course is first it's
so it's funny like i'm
was i'm curious if they're gonna go like
left field and introduce somebody that
we might not realize or if they're gonna
continue what we got going on
or at least personally in terms of what
makes sense
from what i've already seen this season
what i would like to see is
um uh a continuation
of the crow maybe a little bit more
involved
um and then i also want to see a little
bit more
zevo or wrath i want to know a little
bit more and i want to see a little bit
more like of what's evolving in the
dreaming city
and i i want i want to know what's
coming because i mean you can't just say
you know sabbath's got a sister and
she's doing blah and then like where
where like
i want to see some more about i want to
feel the effects of it right now like
they've talked about her i know we have
rathborn hunts but i don't feel like
we're in any danger
yes you know i don't have any of those
vibes like you know like
like you know like there was there was a
real cool thing about even just the
build-up they had was like oh we see
pyramids you see the
world's kind of evolving a little bit
right now it's like you introduced one
of
the or introduced we haven't really met
her yet but introduce
one of the the biggest most powerful
entities that they've been talking about
with sabathune her sister
and i'm not feeling much yeah of that
effect yet
and i'm hoping that that they're just
starting to build that so if
for me personally i want that to
continue to build
that's me nice as always sir
yeah i mean um for me
i think you know obviously we're getting
the conclusion of well not the
conclusion but the continuation of
obviously crow being free and stuff like
that
my gut tells me you know and bungie
they're probably gonna divert a little
bit
and not give us the direct continuation
so no one buddy so i'm not gonna go
there but um you know
got my siren shirt on today so we'll get
to that
we'll oh should i well we're gonna get
there
i'm not going to touch that part but um
that's the other reason why i want to
share that
but uh nah like for me you know i
remember when we saw the initial was it
press materials
and trailers for blight yeah my man was
in the back like this
and zavala was in the front he wasn't
there was a cabal we had the cabals in
the back yeah yeah yeah we haven't
yet to see that cinema we have yet to
see that yeah
right better time now right so my thing
is
you know how does that uh the rathborn
stuff and zebra wrath
affect the cabal and i don't know if i'm
allowed to talk about the rumors so i
don't know he
want me to stay away from the rumors of
the season of the redacted should we
stay away
what do you guys think just the three of
us like for
me i would say the rumors have been
flying if you are on twitter paul
tassie's got his thoughts out there
yeah yeah i'm gonna say if you want to
skip it we'll try and wave our hands for
a little bit
but it was like if you want to talk
about it honestly like we're so close
[Music]
there's speculation i don't think
anything's confirmed but like looking at
iconography and stuff like that people
are starting to
lean a very specific direction so
cognito if you want to kind of
breach that topic crazy hand way if not
crazy
yeah crazy hand spoiler if you don't
we're learning five
four three three two two one one okay
i sound like count count whoever sesame
street
yeah so shout out to uh tassie man he's
put out the article and then um
yeah the rumor is um
callus's sister and from my
understanding can't pronounce named cat
cat
cabinet so from my understanding
she was part of the coup
on gallus so this is a very interesting
figure you know it's a very interesting
figure because of the whole
obviously we know the whole dominance
goal story and how he came into power
but remember callus was in power first
they had to overthrow him thus the
midnight coup
to get him out of there it was a very
cool story so i'm very curious because
to be honest i didn't think they would
if it happens i didn't think they would
go back to calais just yet
i didn't either i'm all about casualties
that's that's why i'm still that's why
i'm still kind of like i
said i did hear that in the like i heard
a couple whispers of that yeah
like in terms of uh like because i think
it was on twitter it's just like you
said it was on twitter
um but it'd just be so weird because i
love if around that time it'd be like
hey and you know also back from the dcv
here's leviathan you know like i i would
i would have expected something like
that
in between the seasons after witch queen
building maybe for light fall
when maybe when we built we formed the
avengers and we get callous on our side
if we don't fight the darkness then you
know maybe all that builds then
so i don't know how much i like i don't
i mean i'm
i don't know much weight it holds i
guess we'll see we'll see but for timing
it would be a little strange to me
it is strange i'll be honest like i
didn't know it would be a little strange
that story to be real if it is yeah
especially when we just started talking
about sabbath and sisters like i just
wondered a little bit about
i'm with you on that one because i'm
torn because
we obviously had the darkness kind of
like squeeze our universe a little bit
and we're like the parts that like left
and we didn't get any idea like
callous like drive away did you just get
consumed as well
just pulled out like yeah we don't know
where the hell device is at or what's
going on or what we can see or whatever
so it's like
it's we it's still like the timing of
things would be quick to see leviathan
come back
but also it's like if it's cabal as you
said if leviathan's here at all you're
like
well i know you got a raid there right
there right there right there why can't
we have those and it's like
i want the back of the back and probably
with reprise stuff
that's why i don't think they're gonna
be there
oh okay that's how i say what's the over
under you they don't
like i think they're i think cabal
because again the cut scene
zaval osiris two cabal centurion
champions whoever sitting around like a
hologram like
some meeting of like collective minds is
bound to happen unless that
you know unless they just threw away
that cinematic so i still think
and by the iconography of what we'll get
to in the season stuff
it looks caball related but i don't
think the leviathan can just like come
back
and be like well you can go to this room
but you can't do the raid this one this
one this one
it was like an underbelly because it
would hurt a little bit yeah
before i i definitely want to know more
about callus's story
but when we just got it yanked i thought
i would just be a little weirder
what about all right kyle's sister and
then we learned some information about
her
and then what about we all we can we all
agree we missed six player
activities yeah most definitely all
right so what about some form of
the medallion
the ups and downs of this discussion
let's see
once again once again i'd be perfectly
happy but i'm just like man why
did we removed it for a season to bring
it back okay
i would be perfectly happy minaj came
back the game is is strongly missing
that because it's an itch that
rathborn hunts just unfortunately
it's not scratching i agree i completely
agree brother like to be
what i what's missing is though like i
still like the sundial i still like a
six
player activity when you're doing the
season
right because the season is a bit of a
it's lesser content but now if you get
more people involved that makes it a
little bit more fun you know i do agree
so do you agree that's what i'm hoping
even if it even if it's nominated which
i hope it is that would be dope
you know i mean i get i get the argument
like yo dude we already had that that's
the same content
but i get it and it's valid it is valid
but that was the
best play activity
i wouldn't now this is where i won't get
mad with reissue
sometimes we're a little hypocritical
but it's our beloved
thing yeah or beloved sets and it's bro
those are brought back i don't see
people complaining people oh yeah we
we won yeah no no you you bring up a
really good point i mean menagerie
even sundown i know sundial like didn't
get the praise i think it deserved when
it first was out just because it can't
be followed
so everybody was calling it we didn't
know we had but
now what we have here sundial was really
good it was really good it was really
good it had rotating bosses it had a
nice
clem a climax with the you know at the
end with the final boss when we got to
the week with the
the final scions we had we could kind of
tailor exactly what we got to choose
like
some of the weapons were really good
like some of those firing line um
what was it no no you're right it was
all about uh
self failure firing line i forgot what
the other perk was looking for but yeah
but
um but yeah there was they they they
have something there too
with all of them gone it it's like
you can feel that void yes you can feel
that void
yeah pour out a little looking for the
1260 weapons that we're gonna lose
that's about two weeks i've been still
for a little bit for a little bit
because man what was it still feather
repeater nope um
oh perfect
perfect paradox uh old-fashioned for
each level
of the loss whatever patron of lost
causes
deal for the repeater the um the uh
reach last that was reached
right breach but what was i'm thinking
martyr's retribution
yeah so all of those are uh yeah yeah so
like season of dawn
is is that that stuff's going away at
the end of
next season or now so season of dawn is
out come now
yep that's what i thought okay so season
of on season of worthy
we literally call it season of unworthy
so it's just like stuck on the podcast
but yeah
literally most of those weapons from
season of the worthy those in next
season
which is a lot of people's place for
yeah seventh serif stuff
yep i believe right and um the the lmg
too
yeah like all of those yeah so quite a
few pieces of the
mods for why can i not think of these
things
but charge
that's a big chunk of those that's next
season so again
this is where i mean sun setting have a
year lifestyle
is really going to start hitting this
season and next season between dawn and
on
la and worthy when those both are gone
i will be very curious how they like how
do they balance it how many re-issues do
we have how much new stuff do they have
do they
go ahead and bring another set of yep
and you know
i don't want to get too far ahead
because i know we're going to talk about
the 12 but with the
the umbrellas coming back i wouldn't be
surprised if they
pour a lot of old stuff into them like
so i'm talking about you we might mess
around open those up and
we might see hammerhead we might you
never even know
what might you know how good my
hammerhead was like that
i bet it was really gorgeous
we might mess around one day and see
spare rations in there you never know
i'm just telling you
i'm breaking a controller that's the
type that's the type of
way like when i kind of hear them say
something like umbrals and then bringing
back
old seasonal stuff and not the new stuff
because they even said they're not
bringing
any of the um because if you think about
they said they're not going to do any of
the uh
hunts of this rathborn hunt stuff in the
umbrella in graham so then it's like
okay
well what are you putting back so and if
it's not going to be the stuff that just
got sunset because think about it if the
season of dawn stuff that just got
sunset ends up in the
in the umbral engrams and the people are
gonna be like well why do we even sunset
it
right so we need to take it all the way
back and i wouldn't be surprised that we
end up seeing gambit and forged weapons
and there it's just my own personal
thought because it wouldn't make they
set old season stuff and it literally
doesn't make sense to put anything
that's about to be sunset in there
because people just get mad
i mean they're yeah there's gonna be a
world that pissed off people when they
go look in those umbrella
and grims the first day i wouldn't be
surprised if if you know that the big
bum
that gets dropped eventually is you go
grab a spare rations
or god knows what who knows so that
being said we haven't really
asked you too much what are your
thoughts on
like reissues i know you guys joked
about menagerie and i'll have my devil's
advocate here in a second
because i do have an opinion so on the
weapons like
it was a week or two ago when you read
like okay so the dungeons are gonna come
back
re-issues like what are your thoughts on
how
sunset is currently being handled i i'm
very much unfortunately like not with it
and in the sense the sad thing is is
i like sun setting the definition
by definition i like sun setting i am a
fan of sun
setting because one of the big things we
had sun setting in the best era of
destiny
taken king we lost the best weapon ever
still dusty one and two we lost the best
weapon ever with gallihorn
we lost icebreaker we lost fatebringer
we lost fill in the list with some of
the best weapons in destiny 1 and
destiny 2. we lost a lot of stuff we're
to crota
we've lost so many things neck or chasm
we lost we lost a lot of stuff
vex met the class we lost a ton of stuff
this goes on and on
no one complained i was too busy trying
to get my touch of malice
i was too busy messing around with all
the new strike weapons i was too busy
getting all the stuff in the raid i was
too busy getting clever dragon and all
the cool things in iron banner and the
list goes on and on and on
so sun setting by definition of just
um pulling things out is is okay for me
if the execution's correct
and with the execution comes if you take
out
like let's say just a let's use a number
value for it if i take out a number 10
i got to put back in a number 10. i
can't have it where the scale is
i i take out 10 and i put back in 3.
when the scale starts it starts and you
start sounds like you're getting hot
you start feeling what you're missing
and so that's that's the first part is
that i'm okay
if it's an even distribution of what you
take
and what's new and that is wrong when
when you take out a 10 and you put back
in a 10 but the 10 you put in
is just the old from the old town so
that that part
then is like like you know like i wish
you know if you're gonna pull it out put
something
new listen new and then the last part
that i think really hurts it is is they
didn't just sunset weapons and armor
which is what they did in in d1 they
sunset activities
and so we're really following the
effects because think about it
yeah i was like yeah this this is
unfortunate i can't use fatebringer and
taken king
but i can go play vaulted glass every
weekend still because i love it right
like you know i can't use um i can't use
word of crota or black hammer
like in wrath of the machine i'm gonna
still go solo crota every every night
because i love it i'm a hunter so we
even had like different stuff to go
tackle it with the same activity yeah
now you're like hey
now raise lighters let me go through a
race rider in there with product yeah i
used to love that i would go solo uh
crota with my hunter with a raised
lighter
um and then don't touch me that would be
my favorite thing to do
but so um but so my that is also where i
think we're really feeling the weight
it's not only are we feeling the loot
we're missing but a lot of people are
feeling the activities we're missing i'm
like man i don't have outbreak anymore
i don't have whisper anymore okay well
maybe i can go do the raids oh wait
never mind
spire crown uh leviathan
um and then scourge scars like they're
they're all gone i can't i can't do
those and then it's like oh you know i
like sundial let me go nope can't do
that
it's like so you know i can't i love the
black armory can i go do the force nope
can't do that
it's like you know i love monagic so we
didn't just lose a bunch
of loot we lost a bunch of fun
activities
and so i think the combination of those
two things too when we don't add the
same amount of act
or at least similar amount of either
activities or armor back
it's like kind of a recipe i feel like
for disaster
yeah your young boy's on fire once again
um not much i have to add to it because
he pretty much
nailed it um yeah i mean that's just
what it is it's just what it is and
again it's just not that equal
distribution so you know when when that
happens
you know rightfully so people are going
to be upset and thus
you know the um the the the disdain for
reissue
you know because it's just like you've
taken so much away
it almost feels like a slap to the face
to get some of this stuff that you've
already grinded for back
so quickly too that's the thing so
quickly because the last point and i
think they don't get
they don't get railed over the cold for
this is that you know when d2 was
announced when we
you know master worked or whatever it
was supposed to be this connection with
the guns and then you have this this
kill count you know you have to kill
count and all this other stuff yeah that
now will reissue it's like well what's
the point because at the end of the day
you're taking this stuff away then
you're bringing it back and if you're
going to do that
like i always suggest it for the people
who already have their god roles
that is insulting you know and to them
it's like well why don't you just let me
keep
my night watch or my whatever right i
agree
just bring the power level up of mine
and if a new guy wants that or
someone was unlucky and they want or or
if you say hey okay you know what i got
my god wrote this but you did add some
new perks
on you know night watch whatever give me
the option
to do it as opposed to strong-arming me
saying
no you can't use this it's in my voice
it's in my possession
and now oh you got to go get it again
that is just disrespected to player
investment and i like one of the things
you said there too
uh lord with the um the part about you
especially so quickly because there's
also there's a right way to do
everything
there's nothing wrong with even bringing
things back later in
and maybe a slightly different variation
how excited were we when they reprised
all of the uh the raids at the end of
d1's life cycle after the april upgrade
oh no it was like oh that's not
imagining my reaction
can you imagine if at lightfall i would
love it
like they did everything's back
here's all the old stuff we're gonna
throw some of the old stuff at you
that's kind of their final year buffer
before whatever else is next but like
lightfall is like
here's the chaos of everything you get
like two years later like
wouldn't be quite as bad be like i
remember this thing or you could go here
like
that's kind of why even you guys are
like oh i'd be happy to see
menagerie it's a great activity it's
cool it's fun but again
we just lost it we just lost it exactly
that's why for me it would feel i know
everybody's like give us menagerie back
and i get that it would be a better
activity with some like tweaks to it and
stuff like that then
probably most other things we're going
to be able to get because it's something
that's already been built they can
give it a different coat of paint and
polish it up and it's like here's some
more stuff but that's also like
we have done this before right and we
want new things
again not more of the same it's like i
understand resources are tight and stuff
like that
and that again we'll get to one other
piece but yeah it's like
the the speed of things coming back
that's the part that
exactly and the last point i mean dakota
which i was going to say too is that
what you know cb killed it with the
whole you know the activities right the
the core things also being
moved away which also hurt them but now
you've got core activities that remained
right
like uh um and shakes shadow keeper
forsaken
that's dropping sunset loot yeah
you're just like you know you didn't
even put something in this
like like they're obviously gonna fix it
now yeah but
that's what it's this combination of all
these and you're so right
and just to continue to piggyback off it
it's unfortunate we got to keep
piggybacking
like i wish there was any more to say
but like same deal with the crucible
it's like we remove a bunch of maps from
the areas that got sunset besides a
couple because i kept pacifica
but besides that they removed i think
the majority of the maps that were on
the old
crucible and then we didn't even get a
europa map not even
i don't even and and this is like from
somebody who isn't even like
i love pvp but like it's obviously it's
not where i focus on
most of my time but that hurts
to get to get a planet that especially
like at least for me like europe was my
favorite destination i had it on my uh
screen saver the old concept art oh my
god my laptop
i remember being on my mac in college
with my europa screen saver on my mac
um and to not have like a new gambit map
uh show up on there
to not have a new crucible map show up
or europa
that that hurts too because then you
removed some of those strikes you
removed some of those crucible maps and
in gamut maps and then there wasn't a
re-allocation of though of what
was pulled so reach and dust yeah that's
the pvp community rightfully so feels
like the reddit red-headed snapchat like
they just don't feel
any love strike even strike got to do
you know
yeah right so it's like yeah anyway we
go on about this you know
we could we could i was like i wanted to
get your thoughts because
generally it's like i see what you're
working on what you've been doing and
you
especially you're like i like helping
people in
all of these things and even for you
like 60 of your help stuff
just got checked like it's gone and now
you're like
there's less things for even me to help
with so it's like hey we're going to do
whisper missions hey we're going to go
help you guys with leviathan because
some people haven't see it
hey we're going to go do zero or we're
like you all have so many fewer options
so even for you
like you said deep stone crypt is nice
because you don't feel burnt going
through it but
there's still less options at some point
you're going to start to see more and
more of the same and you just had a lot
more variety of things to
help people with and experience and have
experiences like have you ever done
leviathan no
are you seeing a place covered in just
shiny gold this place is going to be a
little crazy let's
go nail on the head bro i hear you
couldn't accept that any better yeah and
so yeah i completely agree
so we could talk about it old david yeah
definitely this
guy you know one day it's like he said
it could be whisper next day it's like
all right well no we're going to do um
like you said we're going to go
do leviathan or we're going to go do
let's go get an anarchy let's go do
skurger
you got taraba let's go to tariba all
right you know it it's it's true
so you hit the nail on the head on that
one watch your brothers
on fire yeah all i can say is i think
everybody's waiting on pins and needles
for
joe uh joe's state of destiny
that's supposed to come this coming
season i don't know if it's going to be
the first week they'll probably let the
you know
dust settle a bit but you know in a few
weeks when that thing settles
whoever our guest is that's going to be
a long episode
that's going to be a discussion and a
half i have a feeling i'm probably going
to do like a talk over and just be like
hey here's an hour and a half talking
video of me thinking through all this
stuff so
it's going to be way too long but until
then we do still have some changes that
are coming to season 13
kind of some maintenance stuff but we'll
see first one
seasonal challenges i'm going to give
brief overview for people who are
listening haven't read it yet whatever
and then we'll talk the idea is weekly
bounties are going away
yes so weekly bounties involved a good
chunk of experience
they also involve some bright dust which
we'll touch after this topic
and they also involve your main playlist
strikes
crucible gambit you'd have to go to each
vendor pick them up you can do them on
every character
what they're trying to do it seems like
is
well they're switching over to seasonal
challenges instead of weekly boundaries
that's the main piece here
there's going to be 10 weeks worth in a
season that probably has about 13
so there's going to be a three-week
buffer at the end where you're going to
be able to knock most of it out
each week they're going to unlock some
seasonal challenges so like week one
two and three it's ten or sorry week one
through four it's ten each week that
open up
then week five six and seven it's like
eight seven six six
five five cool so you have at the later
you get into the season they're going to
give you less
certain tasks to go for like i'm sure
when grand master nightfalls open up
that's going to be one of those that's
probably like able to tackle at that
point
trials will be curious without falls
that type of stuff the nice thing is
depending on for one it's account based
so
you don't have to go between multiple
characters to try and be the most
efficient
and also as each week they unlock so if
i
play week one and two then say this demo
for outreach comes out and i just go
diving deep into that one for like two
weeks
and i come back like week five well
everything else is unlocked that i
haven't played yet
i can go back and try and accomplish and
check all of those boxes
um now they did say some of the
challenge deal with seasonal content
but they did say about 60 of it is going
to be
not part of the season so 40 will be
specific
60 will be basically able to be played
by
most people's like even free to play
season people probably be able to deal
with those
some will have more you know specific
difficult objectives like grandmaster
nightfalls winning rounds and trials
um you know primeval envoys and gamut
stuff like that but
there they do say that the level of
difficulty
based in the challenge is gonna reward
you your xp
so this is going to be your way account
wide to earn
xp throughout the season without feeling
like you have to go pick up your weekly
bounties because those are the big chunk
of xp
still going to have your dailies still
going to have your repeatables but that
is the general idea
behind weekly or seasonal challenges
thoughts that's the best summer i could
give so yeah no you you gave her a
killer summary
like you gave a really good one i'm
excited um the piece that i think is is
cool is going to be
um the piece they touched on on the
bright dust being a little bit more
rewarding
i thought that was pretty cool because i
think that's the only thing that i'll
know if you mentioned on that summary
was that right it's also going to be
rewarded as you go through there too
because i saw a lot of people when i was
talking about that get pretty excited
about that
yeah um so that's that's a that's a cool
point um my only
worry with this because it does seem in
theory pretty cool if they're gonna be
having us kind of go throughout the game
and and
do things and have things actually be
relevant where you know me
running through shattered throne doesn't
just give me like a 1050 item that has
no value and i get less experience than
i do
doing two repeatable bounties and i'm
like why like you know like i could
do a hundred shattered thrones and be
have less experience than somebody who
did a weekly bounty
but that's something that's been hurting
me for a while because i normally say
that because i remember back when
all i did was outbreak and whispers all
day and they'd be like how are you still
at season past
30. i'm like dude do you even play the
game i'm like yeah
you got that before it's like yeah i
play 24 7 but i uh
i don't get any experience doing these
things but uh but um so
that part i i haven't really been an
advocate for a reallocation of
experience for a while
yeah so i i am like excited for this in
theory
the only thing i'm a little nervous
about like once again is the execution i
i'm
i hope it doesn't end up just feeling
like bounties with a new outfit on
where you know we just dressed it up
because one of the ones that i saw was
defeat prime evils that's nothing
different than what i picked up from the
drifter
right so my only worry is that it's like
okay this is still
basically a bounty just on a different
screen that i didn't pick up
so that's all that's my that's so i'm
not i'm not saying that i feel that way
i'm just that's my
i'd say worry is that it ends up where
i'm like these are still bounties
um so hopefully it ends up making me
feel like the old activities are
relevant that's what i
wanted to do for me where it's like the
challenge is go beat duel and karu
and then i get a fat chunk of experience
and i'm like that's great and you know
then i feel like i'm doing real in-game
stuff
by going and doing old activities and
other activities just in the world
cognito's about to burst over here and
squirm what's up bud
yeah man the cv is definitely
onto something with where i was going
with it because i was like am i being
when i read this am i being overly
negative and i'm trying to check myself
and i was just like
you know what what's the purpose here
and i'm like okay we're getting rid of
let me think positive what what are they
trying to accomplish here right
so the first thing i said okay well the
weekly bounty has an expiration date
and they probably don't want to follow
us with you know you gotta rush to get
that out
then the second thing and i know shout
out to my man wd press guy he's
chomping at the bit top right does i
know he's ready
he was ready you know i know the bright
dust thing
is as it is something they want to start
rewarding things i believe on like an
account level
thing you know so for guys like me that
just want to do my warlock and i only
care about nothing else
you know like they're coming for me okay
fine but
to what cb said it's like where i'm at
it's like okay
how real different is this from bounties
right
it's not that different and to me i'm
just gonna cut to the chase
all this does not matter if the rewards
are not in place to justify it
but i don't care if i did six prime
evils today
and i don't care like that that's cute
you give them experience we we've
already done that
if you're gonna put a list that's gonna
have fomo
and allow people to do these things
great but
what is the incentive and whatever
reason
the rewards team i gotta come for y'all
y'all haven't been
on the ball it it just we love to do
things shout out to clown
kyle plays we had all right yeah he
wants to be the dogs danglies
we want to look amazing we want to feel
amazing we want to get something amazing
so all this is nice what's the reward
dust okay it's like well i can tell you
it's not armored because we got our
annual
vendor armor set yeah with the different
decals we already got that
yeah so but you're you're you're once
again right out of the bunny
i get that decided better it's just i'm
trying to be nice i'm i really am i i
like the
things in theory they sound cool in
theory and
yeah you know it it's just all i kept
saying is what am i getting
what am i getting when i'm reading this
okay if i do this whatever again it's
something cool
and i don't know how they've they've
lost
there's been a disconnect let's just be
honest since
d1 where the investment
is not matching the reward and strike
specific loot and the last point i'll
say is this
the answers are right there they created
the answers the template exists i'm
gonna drop some inside baseball from
what i've heard
right bungie we know they like to
operate
within um analytics right they're very
analytical
uh we'll get there dear god we gonna get
to the analytics in a minute
you know but the other problem is that
they have this notion where we can't do
what we already did in the past that's
that's not good enough we we've got to
evolve it well they can't say that
they'd literally just put
reissue slapped all over the club we
can't say what we did in the past we're
going to give them what we gave them
before
well true they definitely hate their
words with that but it's just like
again this is where people are
frustrated
it's the disconnect between your their
analytics and their
stubbornness with not doing or
implementing things that the community
already liked that was already perfect
in place
to say no we gotta we gotta we gotta
sauce it up
we gotta do something fresh for you we
gonna you know no
give me what i want that's the problem
you know the old charles the nine
concept yeah
yeah the whole it's just that we like
three b3 elim where's that
this is the kid that is too smart for
his own good
you know they did reinvent the wheel on
everything some things were perfect the
way they were
strike specific loot you know what i'm
saying giving people
cool emblems cool ornaments remember
somebody on um reset era yo it broke my
heart e
oh somebody on reset era put up
the all the iron banner armors of
god i don't even want to look at that i
wouldn't want to look at that
i missed the lion helmet from the honor
that was my that was my favorite uh that
was my favorite
iron piece i still remember that made me
want to be a hunter too
it was like yo this is amazing like
i missed i wanted to be a hunter and
that i never say
those type of things don't come out of
my job i was like i was like i guess i
gotta be a hunter man
yeah all right his buddy gets here too i
gotta be a hunter man
that's my last point it's just like i
said i mean
that's i think the source of frustration
for me and a lot of the community as we
go on with the other points
and with this again in theory sounds
great but if you're not rewarding people
with unique things for these challenges
it's not going to have an impact to make
people want to go crazy
i mean like you i would say you nailed
that
the other pieces too they say these are
based around your ritual playlist
strikes crucible gambit and we
just got done talking about you ripped
out a chunk of strikes there's no new
crucible maps they still haven't
announced any that are coming
gambit like why did you remove gambit
maps there's only six in the first place
and then now we're down to four like
like why like you took time to make like
you're they're literally all the same
it's like a triangle so it's like they
just have their variety to them it's
like why those ever had to go just like
you're teleporting there in your mind i
don't really care how you explain it
just like leap in the game type stuff
but and that's been the problem with the
power grind is that you know going back
and it's the exact same
activities you know and so you hit the
nail on the head when you reduce those
even if like it's cool that we can get a
chunk of experience doing those strikes
it's like you mentioned it's just
it's what we've been doing yeah it's
like that's that's the thing is like i
haven't touched weekly bounties in a
while
because yeah if i do it if i'm like hey
it's like i'm um
right today i'm going to log on destiny
i'm going to work on a couple pinnacles
let me go grab some bounties for those
i'll click on the row
but i was like do i care generally no
and i was like and that's the sad part
is it's taking the weekly bounties
it's putting them in the challenges i
can work on them all like the whole time
theoretically at this point it seems
like you could literally play destiny
in the last three weeks of a season do
all your check boxes if you want to just
like
smash out a season for three weeks and
then back out again
yeah that's it that's weird that's what
i'm nervous about
yeah so i guess we'll see because we
could be off the mark
yeah but but hopefully yeah because
maybe maybe
maybe you know we got we got septics and
you know we got a couple things so maybe
you know
if it's done correctly maybe it'll be
dope but it but these like
concerns we have are definitely like
legitimate and it's something that i'm
gonna be keeping like a close eye on
the first couple weeks the other piece
of this with the challenges as you guys
said
bright dust is going to be involved
we'll talk about where it's at but
bright dust is the other piece they've
said
obviously weekly boundaries are a chunk
of bright dust for many people
there was a point whether it's i think
it was shadow keep somebody could
probably tell me exactly
somebody had done the math of how much
you could earn at kind of the
peak before they started changing the
world of bright dust
yeah and it was like 40 some odd
thousand something like that
uh yeah weekly bounties worthing
and all of that other stuff yes indeed
he did that crazy spreadsheet and stuff
but there was a lot that you could earn
they pulled some of that out of there
now what they're trying to cater to is
it seems like
the person who plays whether it's casual
or hardcore
on one character yeah
sounds like no it's like honestly like i
mostly play on my titan so it's like
some of these changes
some of these changes for me honestly
are not bad because if i just like
i'm going to do everything on my titan i
miss nothing this way
like i'm literally mostly good unless
it's like you got to do it on your other
characters but
you've got the seasonal challenges are
going to be free seasonal activities
six thousand breadth tests so that's
your weekly activities moved into one
place
you've got your seasonal extra is if you
get they say nearly all
don't know what the percentage is if you
do nearly all of
the seasonal challenge check you get a
just
chunk of 4 000 bright dust so total
seasonal challenges 10 grand
not bad i don't know the
equality of weekly bounties if you did
them on all three characters and
everything but
i'm guessing it's less because somebody
did that math season pass bright dust
had its adjustment so that one's up to
ten five so we're up to twenty thousand
five hundred
still on one character weekly ritual
challenges
for all players you get 120 brightness
so these are the ones where if you look
at the tower and you look at zavaland it
says do eight years
now you get 120 bright dust per those
and i was like okay that's not bad
uh you're still going to be able to do
your repeatables um that type of stuff
will be in there your seasonal events
may have a little boost
yeah if you do the weekly ritual vendors
on
all three characters you can get 14 04
40. if you do it on one character
obviously divide that in third so
you know bad math but 3700 something
like that
so generally if you're looking at
just one character 23 24 000 bright dust
roughly just by playing one character
not having to spread
if you put the other two in there you
get about six you know whatever it is
decent chunk more so
bright dust is being shifted and they
say they're working on other places the
season will still have it
you've got your repeatables and other
things of that nature we don't sound
like we're that affected by this one
because we're
like hey i live on one character i don't
have to go venture out for the others
overall just curious you guys thoughts
on this one yay fine what's up
with me i gotta be honest i'm such a
rare eververse shopper anyways in terms
of that
that doesn't even just mean silver i
mean i'd spend so
little time in the eververse outside of
like showing what's on there every
reset for people to see for them real
power you're strong you're strong
like because i don't know why i'm just
maybe i'm just old school but sometimes
i see that stuff and i'm like you know
what like you know
it always happens to me too i'll see
something cool like let's just take it
i'll take an
exa like a prime example i see i'm like
oh that red hive
ship looks really cool this week and
like and then i'm like i wonder why that
wasn't in the hashlet doom strike
and i wore all the parasites or in the
pit of heresy or
and then you know that same thing with a
sparrow i'm like that would have been a
cool thing to grind and hatch led that
was crota's daughter she didn't have any
strike specific loot
i always end up thinking those thoughts
and so i don't i don't know why i don't
get super jazzed up about the eververse
um principle but but
in general though there needs to be a
equal representation of somebody's time
versus somebody opening their pocket so
if they're trying to balance that
i mean i i completely agree because i
don't think the game should be more
rewarding just from
throwing money at the screen um so and
that i feel like way back like not
not so much like as of recent but there
was a time like way let's go really
early back
where with uh back in like the
throttling era where it felt like you
know
you you couldn't like uh kind of get the
equivalent of what you could spend
right so so trying to balance that i'm
perfectly fine with
in theory so if this does bring that
more level then great
because um not everybody's got my
opinion but um
but in terms of am i going to become a
frequent bright dust shopper now no
probably not
it's just me i like i like my tinfoil
hat on the
precious precious on my precious scars
because they got that in the game now so
i'm probably never going to change my
outfit anyway so
you're just going to be the same guy for
a while you already know what
yeah i mean you know i'm always i'm all
for um
you know giving players opportunity to
get stuff in game you know what bright
does so in theory
you know it sounds right now i didn't do
the math
with old pre-shadow keep versus this is
it
you you educate me is it is it less is
it though they they should
still not at that level gotcha gotcha um
yeah i mean that that that's a problem
you know i mean
i mean that's yeah i was like they're
still not on the level of like crazy
hardcore person
who wants to play all three characters
all three bounties do everything do your
seasonal activities somebody who maxed
that stuff out
they're not to that level for the person
who plays on one character didn't do
every single bounty
has a chance to do stuff all season
between the seasonal challenges being
all season long
oh no i didn't play for a week i missed
a weekly bounty there's bright dust i
missed
that won't happen so again who are they
leaning this towards but again
rewarding your hardcore players just to
be on more still not a bad thing so they
i think
they need to make sure not forget about
that person be like oh
some things can have fomo some things
don't need it and that's okay
i think i think e one of the ways
they're trying to bridge that and i'll
see what you think about this part and
maybe they just need to do it in more
cases but the
eight repeatables or excuse me i mean
the eight bounties per
week that give grain a powerful that
give bright dust those are for all
you can do in all three characters
correct so i guess that's one
aspect that i guess rewards the person
who has multiple characters so maybe
it's just finding a balance on a couple
of more of those that's what it feels
like yeah
to me this just feels like uh balancing
the one character guy versus the three
character guy
so if he has the three he's gonna get a
little bit more reward but the one
character guy doesn't have a phone like
he's missing out
because he's i get that you know look i
mean i that that if that's the intention
fine
you know but cb you nailed it to me the
ultimate issue
is as much as you know we want them to
make money and cosmetics and emotes and
we get it
from a business standpoint you know it
doesn't feel good when you see
that hive looking ship in there that we
know should have been in petty heresy or
we
should have been in the hospital doing
strike you know what i'm saying like it
again back to the reward probably
right well let's break the stuff again
i hated to read this 12 and roll my eyes
every time yeah but i was just like you
know i wanted to see the sentence and
now we're going to make a concerted
effort
to you know balance that discrepancy
between what's in
eververse that you're going to do with
the brightness storm versus what you're
going to earn
in game and have that equal you know
what i'm saying and that yeah
yeah that that that's the thing no no
and that's the one that it
i mean you said it perfectly with it's
the hash ladoon strike i saw that ship
the hype ship i think it's this week i
don't know if it's the second last week
the same thought i looked at well i look
at that i'm just reminded the same
sparrow that i have
i probably bought it for bright dust
because i i still sit on like way too
much bright dust because i'm like
at some point there's going to be
something i'm like never going to spend
i'm never sitting low i'm always like
i inch up a little bit i'll be like i
got my one thing for this like
season one thing i don't just drop a lot
so i'm like i don't spend that much but
yeah it's like
that balance needs to be there as like
cognito said
put stuff in there like when's the last
time you could earn an emote
callus is the one that i can think of
facts
and look how crazy people went to try to
finish that and do
and the same with the fire ornament two
ornaments
with that that threw me into spy i was
like yo
i don't even like spy sorry cb but i was
like
i was like yo i've got to play because i
was like not only do i gotta get this
catalyst that's going away from sleeper
i was like um yo i oh everybody's
sitting in the chair i'm like
i want to sit in the chair like i don't
want to be like that you know what i'm
saying
you're 100 right look at the incentive
i don't know who's in charge of rewards
like what has happened
that they are not making this connection
anymore and
it's a big problem it's a big problem i
mean
no no that's exactly what i was bringing
up is like
that's why it's like where was it it was
a hard thing to do it's in a raid but
this thing you get like
dude where did you get that you know
that's what they always want like the
tower to be
is this like hey i see this thing and
now it's like i got it from eververse as
opposed to
go into the game and do it whether it be
wings on your back for trials ornaments
the strike specific loot of i have a
giant hive skull on my head
uh the nightfall crowns that actually
were kind of cool i mean
oh yeah oh yeah i forgot about those
many things that are like in-game
earnable and now it's more of a business
and that's why some people are wondering
it's like
hey they got free from activision it's
like
bungie's been on their own for a while
these are decisions they're still
choosing to do
yeah and yeah and that's like
and i saw even a lot of people
especially when i was doing like helps
for
um leviathan it was a lot of times we'll
like i we gotta get a prestige in
uh because it drops the white ornament
for accuracy and so
it's like so it's you're exactly right
and i mean now like obviously the
majority of ornaments can be found um
in eververse but even just sprinkling in
a couple to some of those activities
made it really cool to like go back in
and do certain things it's just like you
said
because i remember we first time i ran
spire the first time too
on encounter one of uh valkor
my best friend got the toasty mode and
we've never seen it we've done it we've
done it right at lunch
we've never seen i say what is that i
was like
and i started doing three times a week
and it didn't drop for months but
it wasn't it wasn't but it was incentive
and it was the what's that effect
like you know and then i gotta go get me
that like you know so you're right
you're 100 right
yeah cause right now that what's that
effect is
gone mostly it seems like from a lot of
the stuff now it's like there's some
cool things here and there but
half the time the answers have a verse
and that's just kind of unfortunate so
we we beat the reward like strikes like
we talked about half of that stuff with
sunsetting everything else but it's like
it's a thing that like we're this long
into the franchise
we've seen the highs we've seen things
done correctly
and they keep like walking into the exit
door that says
push or that says pull and they keep
trying to push the door
just just come on and speaking of
changes that not everybody's happy about
the sandbox also got some
i didn't see that i had to read over
that a couple of times to make sure i
was reading it right
yeah so is this like bullet at a time or
read at all what do you guys think
um i will let you decide the best
approach weekend maybe
you can do a couple bullets maybe we get
your thoughts there's a couple chunks
that i probably can do
let's do chunks then let's do chunks and
i'm gonna be in the minority on one of
these so
this will be fun because i know some of
you guys are holding your little
controllers out there so
[Laughter]
control the girl controls
hold on
[Laughter]
[Laughter]
now the one thing that is cool about
this first sentence is
in preparation for cross
you know they were looking towards like
2021.
the fact that it's actually saying it
now is surprising
now they said coming later this year it
sounds like if i had to put my specula
if i had to tin foil
not something i would do i'm not the
expert at it but i had to
okay i would i would probably say it
kind of like they did before
work out the kinks oh it's up he got the
you got a lot of kinks that need to be
worked out you got witch queen
big season sabothune stuff going on you
don't want all of that smashing together
despite you know things i'm thinking
summer season 15
launch cross play with it got your three
months work out your bugs your kinks
hopefully that type of thing it's ironed
out by witch queen so they can say with
which queen cross play is completely
live
season 15 is where it launches that's my
suspicion
because they say later this year but not
like i don't think it's witch queen
because we still don't even know what
that'll be i think it's got to be before
and i'm guessing season 15. you're going
before which queen that's what i'm
saying season 15
season 16 is witch queen season 15 is
like arrivals
okay that's where i say it's at what's
your thanksgiving gentlemen
it's crazy i feel like i almost got to
take a step back before i can answer it
because the thing is is
are we there's two different things
because a lot of people have been asking
for cross play like even me i would be
excited to be able to play on pc play
ps4 and xbox i think that'd be great
um and be able to help a lot easier
without having to rotate every day
um in terms of platforms and buying the
dlcs multiple times
um but in terms of like crossplay like
kind of the fundamental piece that i'm
still like
nervous about that makes me nervous if
that was to be the case
is we still have a a problem with with
cheating and on pc
and i'm really nervous that if we're not
asking if we're not if we're not giving
them the feedback
to make this an opt-in process at least
at first until they get the cheating
problem under the under control
gonna potentially i would say
potentially pollute
the console um uh what's it called uh
experience
at least pvp side with the cheating with
n without uh
having an anti cheat in place because
right now you know it's it's
people are still really talking about
let's make sure there's any cheat on pc
so if we are going to go cross play and
that soon
it doesn't seem like they have a grasp
yet on that
on that realm where i'd even feel
comfortable with it even coming at that
point
unless it's opt-in so a lot of people
just say we want cross-play but i think
when the way we say crossbow we got to
be very careful about how we tell bungie
things just make sure you know it comes
in in the right way
but until they have that hammer down it
makes me a little nervous to
to just throw that out and you know in a
couple i guess it would be this year
it'd be in six months six months
yeah yeah yeah it would that would
make me a little nervous for that part
so my thought
is maybe witch queen or eve yeah i would
say maybe like in
i the only part of me that makes me
think it's not witch queen is that
if it ends up crashing and burning it'd
be really hard for them to maintenance
that while they also have a gigantic dlc
so they probably want to get the kinks
out before
so e's thing really does make sense from
like a technical standpoint
but it worries me that it makes sense
they have a lot they got to cover down
on before they can do that in my opinion
unless it's often
and then you know then it doesn't matter
but if it's not then um
then i'm a little nervous in terms of
lowering m and k
or we're gonna we're gonna go there you
go oh hold that
okay we didn't get there so i went too
far but that's my opinion on at least
the the part on cross play
i'd say i i i think that we need to make
sure that
that they're not rushing because that
makes me nervous because the last thing
they need to do is
i'd say upset more people yeah in fact
yeah
um look we i like the idea
uh that first of the first that it was
mentioned right so that you know that
this is the eventual goal
that's what they want to do you know the
other year what was the shadow keepers
when cross saved i believe it was
introduced
you know my gut still i'm going to lean
towards
i'm going to go a little past either
defense of i'm
still going to think they're going to
include it with an expansion
because i think it feels more of a
selling point
when you you know because like with
shadow key came in they're like yo dolly
we're doing this new content
now you could play wherever you want to
play and then it kind of incentivizes
the thirty to four they wrote that like
a few weeks before right
i can't remember i i would assume that
it i wanna say that it went i
thought they did and so that's why i was
leaning at least maybe maybe i'm leaning
in the middle of both of you two between
e and season
e i think it might make sense to be
honest i don't know if it makes like
like it's it's hard i'm in the middle of
both of y'all i think on this i'm trying
to remember so
cross save i mean you guys are almost
looking up the date right now while
you're yeah
let me know when crosstalk actually was
implemented was it which shadow key was
it before shadow
i feel like you know that it's
definitely getting
late i feel like it was like two weeks
for you like to get your save
transferred over finish up your steam
stuff
so that was like there and then people
got to play
a little bit on different platforms
before the next expansion went like i
feel like it was just like
it's like yeah it wasn't maybe the full
season that may be a bit of a stretch so
they like
hey we're gonna roll out cross play
middle of 15 nothing like cb may have
something too
uh right yeah you know kind of in the
low of the season bam
cross plays here how i remember again i
could be wrong i thought it was like
they gave us a prep period before the
season
hey it is it is it i i mean laurie right
so it was
a little bit before in august and then
they said crosstalk won't be fully
functional until
uh destiny 2 new light hits october 1st
but wasn't wait actually was october
10th right
i can't remember it i think it was well
dated
september forever no because they
delayed it to october
um so i do remember that because they
remember they were supposed to hit
september you're right
they got delayed oh no october 1st okay
so it became fully functional when
shadow keep campaigning
right that's why you have the dates but
they brought a buffer period
two weeks before there you go so it's a
prep period two weeks before and then
boom
my thing is in my opinion from a
marketing standpoint it always looks
good as a selling point
to say you're going to do this feature
and i wouldn't mind it to give them more
time i wouldn't be opposed if they did
what you did eat like if they if they
if they do it beforehand and give us
time to mess around i am definitely not
opposed
back to cb's overall point if
this is not if if it flops bro
it would just say this is not opt in
because i know we want to get to the hot
topic in a minute
yeah but this that could be a problem
because as cb said
you know the reality is the kinks are
not worked out over on your ambassador
race platform there sir
and you know the last thing controller
guys and console guys are going to want
to deal with is that level of cheat
we've seen it
upset a bunch of gaming communities i've
seen it upset the call of duty community
at one point
i've seen it upset to see a thieves
community at one point
when it's shoehorned in now i get the
reason for these nerfs and we're going
to get into it
but like like you see me there has to be
an option
opt in option the pools are big enough
that console can play with console
and pc can play with stadium
[Music]
you know i think i think they definitely
if they do that they'll be fine but
let's let's get into that's my theory on
it but let's get it out
[Music]
yeah lots to talk about currently
several weapon archetypes have the
recoil
reduced have their recoil reduced around
40
depending on archetype when using mouse
and keyboard
this results in an issue where players
on mouse and keyboard are able to
largely ignore the stability weapon stat
creating unintended discrepancies and
weapon performance between controllers
and mouse and keyboard
the following weapon archetypes have
their mouse and keyboard recoil adjusted
closer to controller
reduce the difference from 40 to 20
so some people are reading that wrong it
is a 50 change in recoil
just to be clear auto rifle scout rifles
pulse rifles submachine guns hand
cannons and machine guns
couple clarifying points in some cases
pulse rifles sub machine guns and
machine guns
will also introduce some buffs because
they say they say this
knock in recoil to mess and keyboard hit
it too hard
so all of these weapon types for all
controller
for both input methods are going to be
seeing changes
to go along with the mouse and keyboard
change
so submachine guns
basically they were going to reduce the
camera movement but from firing by 24
pulse rifles with mouse and keyboard
changes were kicking a little too much
so they're getting a seven percent
reduction in camera movement
machine guns get a 9.5 reduction camera
movement
now they say we will pay close attention
to how these changes play out when they
go live
and play to revisit individual
archetypes in future updates as needed
outside of recoil we'll get to that
stuff in a second
i'm not gonna say anything yet you guys
are up
let's go cb oh man man man
honestly for me
i think that they should have done it in
reverse
just lower like so just lower
recoil and controller i guess and then i
leave like and and to the point that
they feel like it's balanced
without removing the core experience
that pvp players on the
pc side have been experiencing because i
don't think anybody on pc was asking
for their recoil to be altered and i
don't think it was a problem
but i think it's a problem that they're
foreseeing for cross play right
right and so in those situations i would
i feel like rather um them go reverse
and make something a little bit better
on our side than to make it worse on
pc side at least for me is how i feel
uh about that situation i i would i
would have handled it in the reverse
if it was me because now it's like hey
why was you know my gaming experience
altered when there was no
clear issue on pc like we've never heard
anybody on pc
be like you know the it's just too
smooth give us more requests
and so my biggest thing is when we
introduce things that haven't been asked
for
is always what kills because there's a
lot there's a lot of things being asked
for you know
and so so when you you introduce
something like that
it does make me uh
a little nervous just if it does end up
being a change that really turns people
off now it could maybe not
be that big of a deal you know we don't
know we'll see but you know if it does
end up being a big deal then i
i would have probably rather that they
altered maybe the experience for the
better on the
the console side than or worsening
it i'd say on um on uh the the pc side
that's my opinion what's your thing what
do you think laura cognito what you
think
oh all right first uh for the record
state okay i am biased
i am compromised i am a
controller-loving player
so i have to give that caveat to you
before i say what i'm about to say oh i
know it's coming
go ahead this is how i feel
when when you look at what they're
trying to do in theory
yes it makes sense you have to somehow
even
the playing field right as a controller
guy
i don't feel as fair that the pc guys
get to ignore the stability stack
completely the stability stat is it's
not
really an issue you look at range you
can ignore that
you know what i'm saying yeah so in that
respect
yes the move from a you know
theoretical standpoint makes sense where
i do sympathize with ian where i do
sympathize with ucb is that
you've got this core community that's
been playing the game
one way for this long and they've been
putting up with a lot
and they were like we got a premise we
got purposely they were put up with a
lot
so i gotta defend e in the sense that
if you change my core game experience
so radically that's a problem
like i know i'm biased i'm on the side
that yeah
but i got to be fair to him like it's
not fair
that his whole experience now i mean
look at these guns
all those guys that's like it's
everywhere it's everywhere
i feel i feel the pc community right now
it's weird for me to say it but i do
feel it's like yo your entire core
experience is getting changed
you know what i mean i get for the
greater good
but it just the timing of this again
it's tough that's a good point too
cognito timing is important too
like this is just you know there's
already other fire like you know like
they don't need to throw anything or
gases so no that's a good point
for weeks the community is like yo what
you gonna do about pvp's huh what you
gonna do about pvp
we're gonna make it worse like this is
the first like
the timing this may not have been the
intent with the time
we got you fam maybe it's time all your
weapons
and you're gonna be jumping and shaking
all over the place
that's a good point i think i liked what
you said at the end of the timing
what you think what you thinking i feel
for your pain on this one how you how
you hold it up
how you hold it down yeah he looks like
he's oh okay that's how you guys
that's
so conceptually i get what they're
trying to do
okay for cross play they're trying to
make it to where
weapon random roles matter for both
platforms
in as close of a fashion as they can
now there's a asterisk to this which
also leads into
some of cognito's favor cog
controller has aim assist
i am assist like crazy we got aim
assistant right it's out there that's
why arbalist for example is a controller
oh it's nuts i'm getting more
aim assist on controller is the thing if
you raise the stability
of controller with the aim assist that's
there
they'll be guard by that leads to like i
may as well pick up a controller even if
i'm a potato
i'm at least a somewhat skilled potato
at that point because the aim assistance
stability is better
so i get what they're doing they're
aiming for
not what they're the doing
idea of trying to make stats on all guns
matter for
every input method if i get and if i
never have to look at stability it's
there
zur is literally selling graviton lanes
with 100 stability
don't sleep on it if you don't have it
in case that's kind of cool um
but when you take and again this is
where their
delicate balance line of like i don't
know like the best answer because
if you give controllers with a lot of
aim assist
more stability up to where we are in
controller
that's going to be to a point where like
the drew skis who are already good on
controller
there are people who can mop the floor
with me with controller already
so that's the point where i'm like i can
spin i can like move my mouse and i can
do a 180 probably faster than both of
you guys can
just one of the perks of what a mouse is
able to do as opposed to
thumb stick yeah but on the other side
if there are people who are skilled
enough with the controller already
and then you're going to take mouse and
keyboard down what does that do for the
skill floor now
that being said before i say anything
else there are some people who exploded
on twitter so i want to pull a couple
quotes
[Music]
okay so giggs plays a decent amount
rather skilled player
wait mouse and keyboard is getting
nerfed 20 extra recoil it's more than
that actually
when controllers already have a have
better and still have low skill floor
what in the actual dude
the other pieces didn't they say in the
vidocq before destiny 2 was released
that recoil was designed so that you
didn't have to keep picking up your
mouse to adjust for recoil
because it felt bad to have to do that
they did say that
and there's a quote he's like we may
look in a few places where weapons need
to be handled differently we'll treat
them slightly differently for instance
there's no recoil on guns on pc because
recoil on the controller feels good
i'm firing i'm firing oh i'm losing
control of my gun a little bit that
feels great especially with the
magnetism and all the magic in the
controller
that makes you feel it with a mouse and
keyboard you don't want to be
you don't want the mouse moving without
you moving it so recoil doesn't feel
good
so there's no recoil on pc obviously
like deep philosophies are changing and
they're pulling
out receipts at this point and i get the
game will change
but that's one of those things is you've
had people i swapped a pc
what was it october whenever it finally
went live for d2 i haven't looked back
mouse and keyboard since
now are they going to adjust aim assist
later on for controller that's the part
that i was going to say
i wanted to add in there was the only
way they could do it in reverse they'd
have to
there would be no other way like and i
completely agree with you they'd have to
lower it
so so like is there a point now you take
some now this is the other question lead
into what i'm doing next
what we're talking about next the issue
with like
the laser beam of recluse is where a lot
of this i think
ties to because some machine guns on
controller people would watch my videos
and be like
what are you doing and that's a thing
for pv like recluse was like
for raid races stuff like that people
were using it
that was how long ago and now they're
like well that recoil on submachine guns
that was an issue when recluse was a big
deal two years ago
they're getting to it we're gonna get to
one of the like
buffs that people have also been asking
for
for
years and these are the things like they
gather data they gather data they gather
data they gather data they gather data
and then they're like
at some point they gotta just like crap
or get off the pot like yeah
and then when it comes to like okay
we're gonna get to the rocket launcher
buff it's 30 percent
how long have we been asking for a
change to rocket launchers oh wow
yeah they've been good they haven't been
good since in the past and like that
and that was that was year one and then
we're getting a 30
we're talking almost a third more damage
you're telling me over the past few
years
hey here's ten percent more here's ten
percent more here's ten percent more
so like same principle here is like
you're going for three years and all of
a sudden here's 50
more recoil now if i'm saying that math
wrong but you're reducing the difference
of recoil
40 difference is what it feels like from
mouse and keyboard to controller
to 20 you're going halfway between that
mark so i think my
i'm saying that correctly but it was
like they take this long on some things
and then it's such a big change if
they're like hey there's a little bit
more on mouse and keyboard we feel like
we're getting close not
bam here's the kick in the teeth yeah
it's just like and honestly i can say
all this stuff and until i get in my
hands maybe i'll just be how it feels
i was like i don't know how it's going
to feel and i may be completely talking
out of my butt
saying oh this actually isn't so bad
it'll probably be fine but generally
it's more the idea for me
is the time it takes on some things when
they saw
recluse on pc being a laser beam
controller and mouse and keyboard notice
that was the difference and that was
like last wish that was two years ago
yeah and now we're actually getting
something based on it so it's like
they are so very data driven which we'll
get to a little bit later
but sometimes it takes them so long by
the time they get there they feel like
it's got to be so drastic to be felt
yeah that makes sense yeah it makes
sense it makes sense i mean
look i wish he i just you know in there
defensively i want to see
obviously we got to see it we got to
feel it we got to touch it we got to
experiment and then
before we jump off the handle but you
know theoretically it just doesn't
you know it doesn't feel good you know
if i've been playing if the
the reverse happened and i've been
playing on controller
all this time and now they're doing this
dramatic controller change
that is jarring this game because
yeah a lot of this is muscle memory
right this is what you used to you've
been doing this so long
that these are huge gameplay changes
fundamentally and
look again timing timing timing you know
what i'm saying at the end of the day is
you know it's never the good time to do
things but at the end of the day it's
like
you said it best eve when the community
feels you don't
listen and
then not only do you not listen to what
was asked
you then put in this new thing that is
gonna really infuriate people
and then not even say hey remember i
didn't forget you see at least at the
end of the line people like hey
pvp guys we got something coming you
know in a month
this is their problem they're not saying
anything and then it's just like
you're gonna just piss people off it's
something with pr
something with the communication there
it's still
it's not terrible because they are
transparent they're better than other
games i'm not going to disrespect you
yeah
but it's just the community has been
yelling for a minute
someone needs to get in front of it and
say hey
here's your bullet item this is why even
if the even if you got bad news
this is why we're not going to address
this right now yeah because
this you know what i'm saying this is
this we all resources are here
blah blah blah that helps calm the
the crowd down the fact that they don't
do that and then they just like yo by
the way you're going to get this in
there and so the crazy thing is
though okay that's a good point they
always do all the like remember at the
bottom every tops like the known issues
that we know about
yeah and those are usually like more pve
related but it would be cool if they
did announce some of the things that
were at least looking into on the pvp
side as well if they did one that was
kind of pvp based that'd be kind of cool
right i think the only thing that could
have got them to think that this was the
right timing to do that
was i think they all got together and
they were like
we can't introduce this to pc right
before cross play goes live they're
going to be infuriated that they didn't
get it
right right you're trying to so here's
here's an amazing idea how about we tell
them right now
yeah so they have so they have seven
months to practice to practice it and
you're like yeah that's a great idea
then they put it out and now everybody's
mad
it's like so like the flip side i can
kind of see like maybe i get it like
what was thinking but like at the same
time it's like
no like not not now like somebody's been
like you know what maybe like let's
let's let's fix a few other things and
then we'll like ease them into that
i'm okay listen but no one likes bad
news right
yeah i'm this type of person i am you
could tell me
yo the worst news as long as you tell me
then you give me time to process which
is what they're doing
that part of it i don't mind but the
problem is when you
do this but you ignore all the other
things people been yelling at
yeah you're yelling what's going on pvp
where's the renewed focus where's the
reward what's going on blah blah blah
you don't address any of it you don't
even say hey we're gonna look to do
talk about this in the future twab or
nothing and
you just say hey better days are ahead
i'm so excited
i'm so excited about what's gonna come
now you guys i can't wait it's in the
best date
that's not gonna sit well we gotta die
you know i don't know what's going on we
need to eat back
i don't think somebody said that in chat
i don't know what's going on but
you've got you cannot ignore things
that's my thing you can't ignore
that's all yeah and i hear that makes
sense yeah
i think we got that blur pretty well e
yeah you kind of killed that one
um yeah man other than that
outside recoil adjustments there will be
some buffs i touched on one already
because it just kind of led to my point
and some nerfs because you know those
things have to come in pairs
buffs rocket launchers have fallen
behind other heavy weapons in most
measures of effectiveness we're pushing
them into more of a burst damage rule
increase their
damage as i said by 30 percent exotic
rocket launchers have been adjusted
individually
and are affected by this change to
different degrees ward cliff coil
there's some ones that probably would be
a little bananas so i'm sure they'll
tweak them where they see how is it
tomorrow
what i thought tomorrow yeah they'll
probably
tweak each exotic one individually yeah
probably but this paired with your uh
charged with light mods
mods
extra damage on top yeah i think it's i
think it's
i mean i i hear it did take a while um
but
at least i guess with them their thought
process probably they're bringing back
the rocket launcher from is the moon
what's it called again it's um what's it
uh
they're bringing back the i know what
you're talking about you know what i'm
talking about
the moon um oh dude you you know i'm not
exactly
so maybe they think that you know now's
the time to you know they're getting
that background is like is the pursuit
weapon gonna be
a rocket launcher
[Laughter]
yeah it's here okay okay cool cool yes
so
i don't know maybe they think that's the
time to bring it back um or maybe
they're just nervous about having it
end up back like the cluster bomb era i
don't know like what made it take so
long
but yeah i guess we'll see
[Music]
next one we've got is fusion rifles
usage is very low
and they feel they're an unreliable
choice in crucible compared to shotguns
increased fusion rifle damage fall off
start distance
in case that's not clear when the damage
starts to fall off at a specific range
they're pushing it farther based on the
range stats so with zero range you get
six percent more follow up more time
before it falls off
uh 16 with 100 range so you're getting a
little farther for those little
bolts to have full effectiveness
basically
reduce camera movement as well by nine
and a half percent same as machine guns
finally this was a weird one breach
grenade launcher usage is very low
outside of mountaintop which is mostly
gun or at least just base crucible
we believe part of the reason is that
the loop of hold the trigger to arm and
then release to detonate is challenging
to execute
particularly since projectiles can
bounce off targets if the trigger is
held
breech grenade launchers projectiles
will now detonate on impact with a
character
even if holding the trigger so the main
change is if it hits another
guardian it will it will detonate
like a direct hit um it still sounds
like it will bounce
as intended for the other places that's
a little interesting
yeah one what you got what'd you think
about that cb i'm curious
i mean one mountain top got sunset i
mean i'm not gonna
fake i i don't think i've seen many
people running around with
any geos so i mean maybe that's that's
where they're thinking they're trying to
make it where
hey you know other things exist outside
of mountaintop you can still use
these types of weapons it's kind of what
i kind of hear from that because i think
once
everybody said down the mountaintop in
pvp at least not pvp you know
i think a lot of people you know kind of
forgot the the weapon type existed and
this is probably what it is just
bringing that not for you i i i think
that they definitely
i'm a little nervous i think of people
like i'm i think this
might be crazier baby i don't know like
i know
it's like honestly you could picture you
know people instead of snipers if you
have a tight corridors map or something
just try and bank some around corners
and if you get a direct hit on somebody
there's a pretty yeah it's gonna blow up
already and then you can push so like if
like
all right everybody's trying to break
everybody's like sitting on two sides of
a weird door
you get a perfect bank shot you get a
hit as opposed to being lucky for the
explosion
bam all right sweet got it yeah it
almost gave every single
rocket oh excuse me grenade launcher
like an intrinsic like proximity
yeah it's a second it gets close yeah is
this mountaintop
properties or uh
and then as for nerfs sniper rifles
usage has dropped in crucible
so read that line first usage
has dropped dropped even
if uh we've observed that it's hard to
challenge some
even with that they've said it's hard to
challenge someone with a sniper rifle
even if you get the first shot at an
enemy they can't often respond with the
win the fight increase ads flinch to
snipers when taking damage from other
players
now it's weird to put those two
sentences together because honestly if
i'm
plucking somebody with an auto rifle and
they still can head shot me i'm just
like scratching my head like
how is that even possible because in my
head like i should be moving you off the
target off your spine but on the other
side they're like you spinal it's you
you're dropped and i'm like okay that's
just a weird decision
but yeah i like the idea behind it
personally just because
if i pluck you with a scout rifle high
impact rounds or something have a reason
at that point
you shouldn't be able to like bounce
back to my head after i hit you twice
like already that's always felt bad to
me but i'm sure some people are going to
be not happy about this
you know i think that i agree oh whoops
i agree with that e but like at the same
time though i just i'm nervous
that i don't want to end up back in the
vanilla d2 era where you got tapped once
with anything and the next thing you
know my sniper was
pointing at the sky because there was a
time where recoil was a huge
one sniper where you know it was almost
unusable if you were getting shot at
so i hope that they don't go too crazy
in either direction well they don't say
it
they don't say they've got you my
problem is that that's why i'm sitting
here like kind of like i don't know i
feel about that until you know it might
not be noticeable or
it could be like this is low-key like
not good you know fall out or
cool guy or one of those guys is going
to be doing testing okay here's a scout
rifle
here's a high impact scout rifle here's
the scout rifle and this is the amount
of flinch in your animation you got high
impact reserves you got
what it like i've been like somebody's
going to do that science testing for
sure
oh they're curious if somebody figures
out like the before and after because
this yeah
people are recording stuff right now to
be like all right how does it feel now
i'm exactly with you i just feel like uh
it theory it needed to happen because
i've had that i've shot
a sniper you know hard scope and moved
him off the spot
and he's able to recover in mid fight
and still
without even dipping away and resetting
like this is the same engagement
that shouldn't happen you know what i'm
saying now i'm with cb though you don't
want it to go all over the place without
snipers are
useless and then you know they can't
it's not even a viable thing and like to
each play
they already said the usage is going
down as it is so
yeah it's like an interesting way to put
both of those sentences at once like
yeah usage is going down so we're gonna
nerf it
you know i'm sorry
i'm sorry this is basically the sentence
but like i hear them but like also like
you know they got to be careful with
that one for me i'm on the fence i got
to see it
i got to see that one yeah me too final
piece
swords are extremely dominant pvp now
why do you guys think that is right now
patrix that's the one
limit like yeah and i say activities
that promote
using that yeah you know i think some
companies stomp you've got
you've got some things that at this time
65 percent of players are using swords
for the majority of gameplay encounters
in destiny 2.
while we are introducing a buff to
rocket launchers to make them a bit more
enticing we feel that swords do too much
damage compared to other options reduce
sword damage by 15
cognito you're grinding you gotta go out
little liquor man it was a good run
about it listen lebet's still gonna be
good but i mean let's be real
we knew this was coming oh i know this
we was running a rough shot on these
guys we just run a rough shot on the bus
now look i like
swords i love having fun with him it's a
great powerful feeling a lot of people
are sherpa i make them get lament
and when they get it they're like
they're so they're running head first
into battle
with the left the left trigger charge
okay here's the other side of that coin
why were swords
good linear fusions suck yeah
yeah rocket launchers have been in the
dumpster fire for a while
grenade launchers aren't bad they're
somewhat inconsistent but you know they
have some burst to them
but why are your heavies leaning one
direction because you made one powerful
right now they're bringing one up and
knocking one down at the same time
as well as the here's rocket launchers
that have a charge with light mod that
go with them
datto is going to be like you can get 60
out of a shot that hits like a truck
yeah that's true it but it in in so it
defense
you throw that lucid blade on the mitt
that is true
what okay lament was just brought down
and the swords weren't touched
that was what i was thinking the next
thing i was going to mention is
what is what is the random swords gotta
like yeah the random shield
you're hook what i can't even remember
that one is
those are like those aren't crazy
powerful
they're decent but they always feel okay
that's a great point
i mean they proved that they can do it
to just one weapon when they just
brought down
flying guillotine so i think they should
they had the template i don't think they
needed to ruin every sword for them yeah
every other story shouldn't have got the
wrath
like oh i got my little uh what was that
new monarchy like sword i got my
for honor over here i'm like
maybe not it's made all the other purple
swords useless
and that's just more than anything more
than they needed yeah you could not do
them
account is bananas bonkers we know that
that was probably gonna happen i agree
yeah but on the other side i still think
like the other
like your base swords even guillotine
was like
powerful they knocked out that down a
peg did it is now it's getting a double
nerf
yes that's a good point that's a good
point
i i you you you're right you're right i
mean it it's a double nerf
unnecessarily but the reality is one
weapon is really dominating that and
it's lament
and coupled with the fact that 65 i'm
not going to say it's skewed
but like you said i mean a lot of people
are using it for eight tracks and you
know
yeah yeah specific encounters so i could
see it
but um i would bet a decent amount of
your bass
that is playing depending on where these
numbers are pulled from
because this is late in the season
population's down trials is literally at
its lowest it's
been in almost forever charles was that
it's one of its lowest for the weekends
so the people who are running right now
your cb's doing your carries what are
they going to do
they're going to be as efficient as
possible right now the one exotics there
you know you're busting through
encounters running through raids
crushing bosses
that's going to be your efficient way to
do it but that is like your main
choice not saying it's the only choice
but
it's a good point for us to see i think
lumet is going to survive this though
i mean lament's still going to be
powerful but now you literally like
wonder
what does your base sword look like now
right the legendary sword yeah
they're useless in my opinion that's
good that's going to be
unfortunate yeah the damage testing will
be interesting they have a couple exotic
changes
uh any exotic that has like a specific
bug
or a weapo a perk that would like go
away when you switch weapons
had the same thing that would go away
when you pulled out your ghost they're
going to fix that for ace of spades
terra button hawkmoon
it's good borealis and hawkmoon have a
custom quick animation for switching
damage type
all i can say is thank you i can't tell
you when i did use hard light which was
not much
how many times i would hold the reload
and then apparently would think i did it
again and pass the one i was on
so like it might just be like quick like
double tap or switch or something just
like fake or whatever it's got to be
cool
speaking about what you call it um
for that hot moon it's really good both
of those yeah
both of those two that's the first time
i used borealis in
like a year i was like yeah yeah no they
both work really well there yeah oh yeah
so i'm looking forward to that because i
want to run that mission again
uh duality getting increased damage uh
distance fall-off
both firing from the hip and ads reduce
max buff stacks from seven to five and
the stacks do more damage so they're
giving that a little more
like ease of functionality yeah uh
something with sturm and then also
merciless will do what it's supposed to
do again that
that gun man i swear it's been through a
lot it was a heavy at one point it
doesn't have to be
broken multiple times yeah marshall has
been through it
and before we go we plan on taking a
quick tuning pass at arbor list
our the art with yeah
list or console i hear arbalest is just
terrorizing me bro
it is yeah no it is but they're not
addressing it immediately that's what we
need to
say in that part too what does it say
again it says uh sometime in season some
time
in season sometimes they're tuning past
and it's like
so last piece um
they say well i'll get to the other one
we know it will be difficult to
understand the scale of buffs and nerfs
would having these changes in your hands
not to mention some of the new perks
you'll hunt as you
start navigating content of season
they're adapted as always we're excited
to see the changes and we'll be eager to
hear your feedback
i will say when they said hey changes
are going to be coming back faster
sandbox still seems to be about once a
season right
yeah yeah that doesn't seem to be
does it seem to be increasing frequency
at least my understanding i would agree
do you guys
would you wish for quicker changes do
you feel like
i kind of promised that didn't follow
through am i talking out of my butt here
no so far i know so far you're on the
money i mean i'm hoping that as we
continue to see
this progress maybe we start seeing that
a little bit more but
the reasons that they said you know
certain things were going into dcv
and certain things needed to happen for
you know a lot of new stuff to come
or for quicker changes to get out um
outside of
i'd say disabling certain things i mean
they've proven they can do that quickly
they can disable something if they want
to they they want to disable someone
they definitely can turn something off
they've proven it
but outside of that i would say i mean
you're not wrong
so the final piece is crimson days each
year we look forward to february is the
time to celebrate the bonds of
friendship throughout the community
shout out to all the friends of the
community you guys are amazing these
guardians have come to know the
celebration as crimson days it was one
of our first seasonal events in destiny
1
tradition that we carried to destiny to
while there was great enjoyment of
crimson days
we feel it's been missing the mark in
terms of quality over the last few years
i wonder why
as such we have made the decision to
discontinue crimson days moving forward
well we'll miss the event this will move
this move will allow us to focus
for alternating seasonal events ranging
from quests to activities and more
we have quite a bit planned for season
of the redact and we hope we have
um and our hope is that we've maintained
or at least improved the quality of come
to expect from us
crimson doubles and crimson days are
going in the dcv
that last sentence was the part that got
me to be honest the one thing that i
actually
enjoy uh for the most part like that i
think consistently throughout all of
crimson days no matter if it's been d2
or d1 or it's been that crimson
doubles playlist and hearing that
another crucible mode that
some people i know like from the
reaction that i saw especially when we
were going to the 121 stream
um it's like we're losing something else
yeah like in terms of crucible so
i i kind of feel for anybody else that
like at least enjoys the doubles
playlist um
that was the biggest thing for me it's i
thought maybe they're gonna stay at the
end we'll still keep doubles and bring
it around every once in a while
but hearing that going on the dcv was
kind of um a little unfortunate
uh you know it's to me this is sadly
similar to like fractured rallies where
just like they just couldn't
yeah yeah right or get it get the
engagement how they want i
i seen this you know coming yeah um
my main thing to your point though i
would like um
you know they killing it they are
destroying you right now they're like no
you're gonna get out there you're gonna
do this work
oh please don't make it even prescott i
don't know if i got that much in me book
please be nice
people who are watching accumulated
twitch points
they can cash them in to do push-ups and
sit-ups just kind of
i'm gonna do it with them oh my god
where are we up to four days these
savages bro
what's it thirty-five what's up
something is in my eye i apologize
okay i'm gonna be over there sweating my
ass off here in a little bit
you guys are doing it for cb
anyways crimson days um yeah we're
talking about
the crimson doubles we'll do that
towards the end of the podcast because
yeah i was just like
i mean let's be real you know it just
wasn't really popping it wasn't really
motivating people i
didn't remember the community getting
super popular i mean we had the same
what was the boat
the last two two years yeah both of
those right
right and the rewards and stuff so no i
agree no 100
it makes sense um i did what was my
saddest part was the playlist for
crucible yeah i did like the playlist i
didn't like the cops
back together yeah that jay was cool
that joe was cool i thought it was
really cool
yeah i agree i did like the place
i'm just looking at my fate being
decided over here i worked out today
guys
dakota said we could split them and we
could do that too if you want i'll just
we'll see how much i got i might have to
pass a few extra off but yeah we'll see
what we've got
whatever i'm gonna stick it out i'm
gonna stick it out with my brother
so one thing about crimson days is
basically i think a telling sign because
we've talked about it before
and it's bandwidth within the studio
yeah and i think this is just another
sign of that
it makes sense how much again we wonder
they say they have 25
of the people that came in even if they
didn't lose anyone
of course you know people come and go if
they were 600 maybe they're 800 there's
the other game out there maybe they're
four or 500 maybe they're about the same
i still wonder for one how much a bungee
is working on
destiny and then of course like we see
their capacity is truly at its max like
when something like crimson days can't
get a fresh coat of paint
one new weapon nothing there's so much
they're like we don't want to do it for
the third year just another copy paste
even though they mostly just copy pasted
the last like the donning it's just a
little bigger
yeah i know this wasn't like a renowned
event so it's like this is just the
first one on the chopping block i'm just
starting to be curious what else is
going to fall onto the chopping block as
well
yeah and you bring up a good point and
then to take even a step further than
just them losing i think we can all
touch on a little bit too
especially um like for myself
in the it world and i know you have
something to say
i know you all something to say um
working from home and having everybody
remote
even like building like the i'd say that
i mean i'm not building a small scale
application right now but it's by no
means something that's going to be used
by millions of people um
it's hard when i get coordinating that
effort
um even on a small scale team where my
team's you know
five six noise almost 10 people at this
point
um but putting together like
a game like so to lose activision then
have this where they can't even see each
other in the same
office it's just a perfect storm of it
it's tough
like i just think that it's not even
like there's multiple factors i think
it's the
like you said they're losing a lot of
people and then they're not even in
their studio
yeah i say part of it i mean it's a
miracle you know we've gotten
a lot of the stuff we've gotten to be
honest just from how do you feel about
that i mean we've all been working from
home
yeah i mean it's it's just different
collaboration right it's it's you you
can't collaborate the same you have to
adjust and then
i think for me it's just consolidation
they look again they look at metrics
they're looking at consolidation of
resources
and say hey how much resources are we
really going to put to this look at the
engagement
it's actually driving which is probably
not that much and then like it's
probably
not worth the effort we could put our
resources towards other things
hopefully rewards hopefully reward
that's it but um yeah i think that
that's what it comes down to
it's just literally resource management
and um in that case again i'm not
i think the community's not gonna cry
river on this i think they're gonna be
okay
yeah with this decision overall you know
saying
but yeah you know i agree i agree
yeah sounds like that's mostly it we
know there's bugs they're working on you
got your movies of the week and
other stuff in there it's pretty cool um
so the big things at this point the
other big thing i would say that i sent
to you guys as well a couple
fun little things we had the new armor
for trials get teased
yes yeah yeah yeah kind of curious if
you guys are like
pumped going to be asking if the carrie
is going to be paying out the money for
it what do you
know i'm going to see you got me but uh
but in terms of the look no because it's
funny you know when uh i was streaming
they're like oh a new arm
like uh so they posted right around the
reset today um
check that out we might want to maybe
maybe i can link that so if anybody can
see it
um but that maybe hasn't but in terms of
my thoughts on that
i think it looks pretty dope at least
for a first glance i think
my favorite pieces that i really did
like i loved the way the warlock helmet
looked
and i really liked the way the titan
chest piece looked yeah at the first
yeah the first glance i liked what i saw
uh how do you guys feel
i think i'm with you i think um for me i
i like that the look
itself the design itself is very
egyptian more about that you know what
i'm saying and i'm always about that you
know i'm saying i'm always about the
roots stuff like that
but yeah i thought it looked cool i want
to obviously it's very dark so i want to
see
more of it in the light but initially
like i was just happy i was like
let's see that shirt [ __ ] let me see
let's let's let's see that's right
let's go there we go i got a rebel
man that's what i got let's go yeah man
so
at the end of the day like i said i was
just happy to see that okay you know now
now what we need though
is the commitment to pvp and it's nice
you brought the armor that's cool
yeah but let's what about what are we
doing what are we doing
what are we doing for trials you know
let let's get this
pvp focus that the community is so angry
about right now
you know taken care of and they'll
finally i was just gonna say is like
the other piece of discussion was like
cosmo tweeted out literally today at
4 55 my time apparently so so
yeah the team is aware of feedback
around three peaking and currently
discussing possible options
no promises as we are still
investigating what changes are viable
since it's a complicated issue that
affects both emotes swords
and any potential future third-person
weapons
now there's scorch cannons which is fun
they're swords
i mean yeah you can do stuff in your
supers if you're gonna waste those on
those
do they have a plan for anything else in
the crucible like any other third person
weapon they kind of hinted at it though
right based on what he said where he's
like
in future plans so i don't know what
they might
have planned but i think that tweet was
in direct response to the twab
um yeah after the twab launched uh there
is kind of like a ton of people are like
like that you know that we're listening
meme kind of came back yeah
like we've been talking about swordpig
you know for like the last you know
since the birth of all of this and they
haven't acknowledged it so i think this
was a response to kind of what was
being said yesterday um i agree it's
definitely something that needs to be
addressed
i agree yeah i'll say that what do you
think
i was like i mean i'm not a heavy trials
player but it is
like the acknowledgement is a start yeah
because that's like people like three
peaking three peaking three peaking
three peaking for the love of god three
peaking
they said something why did it take for
this long for them to say it's like
we are aware you guys have feedback
about this we're looking into options
waiting to see it's like it's it how big
of an issue say
something faster yeah i was like because
they still aren't promising anything
it's not like it'd be like hey we have
this
we're testing things we're seeing how
systems react to certain things
something's in the works right now it
feels like it's on a whiteboard as a
bullet point as something they're
looking at and
it's probably been up there for months
since trials has been a thing and three
peaking has been talked about for as
long as trials came back
so it seems like one of those that like
it's good to see
why does this stuff have to wait as long
again people like rocket launchers
rocket launchers rocket launchers
okay now here's 30 percent they finally
do it so it's just i guess sometimes
resources brother what
resources man no i i get that i don't
know
knowledge you're right yeah
we're going to do some research we're
going to see on our end we're going to
do some testing
there's a lot of interconnected systems
say that type of sometimes they are
so transparent like sometimes they like
word vomit more than you're like
i've never seen a dev tell me this much
and then other times they can't say
systems are complicated we're checking
into things we're going to see if this
is a viable option we've got a lot of
systems that connect to this
right it's not forgotten like that's one
of those things that i feel like
and maybe that's one of those somebody
ups like don't say anything yet because
there's too many i don't know but it's
just like acknowledge is just the thing
yeah acknowledgement and set and proper
expectation
so that we are not going crazy but like
you said that was a perfect example they
they acknowledge it this is why you know
when get to it but it's a more complex
issue than you guys think
people will understand that people would
generally understand it but when you say
nothing that's what gets them in trouble
you know what i'm saying they just got
to work on it they still have to work on
that
yeah i think they need they think they
need to be either already
having like an implementation or fix
ready yeah be close
before they say something yeah perfectly
fine with you know this this this and
this
are on the table and and we're looking
at it and and right now you know we got
to do
some careful consideration but right
just know where we we got it we got on
our radar
i agree it's all the communication yep
communicate setting proper expectations
yeah
yeah we will be very curious to see well
that's most what the twab has do you
guys have anything else for just the
state of
i mean so for you we've talked about
kind of what we want
what are you looking to see
information on and you can talk i'll
listen to it later i'm going to go start
work
um oh wait start what work i'm going to
go start my
exercise work i'll see how many i do and
then i gotta tell you tell me tell me
how many
i gotta do after you you just tell me
what i gotta do i'll do what i got
and then if my arms give out because i
did literally work them today i'll pass
off a few but
sit-ups i'm gonna try and knock them all
out push-ups we'll find out
that being said for you the state of the
game from joe is coming
whether it's two weeks three weeks four
weeks whatever what do you want to see
answers ideas story armor three-point
whatever i mean that's my
like that's my little thing but it's
like what are you looking forward to
seeing in that what would you like to
see answers
and if there are things that they don't
touch do you think they'd be like
you got to talk about this good bad or
other like where are you at with the
state of the game what would you like to
see when it comes because
by the time it comes back we won't see
you i'm going to be back there
i want to i'm not a good luck
i want them one big thing oh green
screen going down
the set up before we got to get that you
got this you got to work like listen my
boy don't work out before like this is
an extra dedication y'all like this
already worked out and pushed his body
to the limit but that's not the last
word the cheetah is
back the cheetah
[Music]
that's a true warrior right here this is
a true one this is a man of the people
okay this is what he brings man
it's unbelief this man he's a [ __ ] he's
a machine absolutely
not missed a beat give him the sword
esoteric of sit-ups oh my gosh
dudes speed running solo flaws
first the first side of
the last word podcast i don't know what
will look at that
right okay okay all right
so i'm gonna take his push-ups because
he did tell him
i'll take your push-up and then he's
doing the push-ups too
quartz height
this is this is insane i guess this is
insane i gotta get back into the chat
i gotta get some more this man is doing
too much this is a man of the people
[Applause]
he's not
dude this is literally this is that solo
dungeon god that he put out
this solo push-up guy he's still oh he's
going he's going for the triumph now
he's going for the triumph y'all oh my
gosh this is this is for the seal come
on man
come on come on real
how many do i got to match because this
man really just he just put on like that
he really did
yeah he put off the people he really do
whatever he says oh he's sweating too
sweating
oh holy holy holy how many do i need how
many do i need
how many how many how many was that that
was a push-up 50 put
30 push-ups 50 setups all right here we
go i have a green screen coming down
30. you're gonna do four thirty
not a leopard
oh here we go here we go this man's
already obese though this man looks like
he just works out
he's a beast check out cv yo he's my boy
i don't just call people my brother
they're not my brother oh you can't
oh he gets out of the textbook behind
the screen i think so he's going to make
me look
good let me see he should be on street i
hope that's
all right here we go there we go here we
go
i am yo this is a
rare occasion the cheetah has already
set the bar
he has already showed us he's the
essence
this is youth and acceleration but at
the end of the day gentlemen ladies and
gentlemen
this is premium con cb has matched
ibontis he's going for he was inspired
by a a an unbelievable performance
shout out to the young legend the young
legend all right you might want to leave
just know
hype all that fun stuff while i was
getting killed out there thank you all
very much you guys are amazing
i demanded them i said they must
subscribe i need to see some cheetahs in
there i need to see you like i said
that's
true dedication man true dedication
these two like i said yo
like i said there's something else yeah
go away
i'm definitely tired yes he's this yeah
he's
that was classy that was closing
i'm tired the way you said it i'm good
i'm good i'm tired yeah i'm good i'm
done
what was the question they're getting
caught we
that was some real work you just put in
yeah i still didn't hear you guys
again one more time i still didn't
process it
of destiny 2021 joe groth joe
is gonna put out his like big giant deep
dive
for 2021 what do you want to see in it
yeah what do you want to see in it the
big thing for me
i think is the sun setting piece again
and they the direct quote they gave us
was they're removing stuff to bring
stuff in that's going to put the whole
stuff to shame
i haven't quite seen that yet in the
form of activities or weapons
um yet at least and i'm really like one
of the things that i really hope that's
addressed
is kind of the what's removed versus
what's put in
right um and what's hopefully
coming in terms of rewarding player uh
i'd say activity yes so one one thing i
really want to be talked about is the
state of the loot in the game
activities as well but i'm hoping that
maybe just
we'll see those activities pop up as we
have the seasons continue
um but one thing that i really do want
to hear talked about
or talk about is like what's coming in
terms of what we're gonna be able to get
our hands on and what's going to keep me
playing
outside of just you know xp and bright
dust that's something that's really
important for me
yes um that that's that's one of the big
pieces i mean obviously i want them to
address a lot of the things for the pvp
side of things like i honestly would be
perfectly fine with them
neglecting our like you know the pv have
for a little while even and giving me a
little bit more on the pvp side of
information as well
i think they really put pvp season i
would be fine i would
legit take take away everything for it
and get things right like it's important
both sides are so important
like even back when d1 was on struggling
at a couple different points
oh yeah charles was carrying it
in the in the directory yes
so absolutely i really want them to give
the pvp side
some more love like that's at least me
um on pve the big thing for me is
what are you going to put in the game to
make me want to play it more yeah
so i'm hoping that that gets addressed
what about y'all
yeah same day i mean um you know
definitely honestly i actually don't
want
pvp to be addressed to the thing because
i was hoping pvp would be addressed
before he does the big
state of the union state of the game
thing i'm i'm hoping
that you know maybe just more little
tidbits here because i really don't want
the community to have to wait
as long for what the hell is going on
that's a good point that's what i'm
saying
yeah that's a good point yeah if it
happened don't get me wrong if it
happens it happens when it happens but
as long as it happens right so that's
the main thing um
i'm a little different though um
he knows where i'm gonna go with this
but it's just like where are you going
ah remember my issue
resources resources resources you know
and i'm gonna i'm gonna die on this
horse for them i have to look at what
people
i'm a person i judge you by your actions
i don't judge you by what you say
yeah and what they've been telling me is
oh you know
um you know we're still gonna push our
content we're still gonna do this in a
seasonal format we're gonna give you
this
but in the same token they're saying
we're never to give you a an expansion
the size of forsaken ever again
right yeah so did say that yeah so to me
you know again them by themselves i have
to look at the body of work
shadow keep beyond like the seasons in
between and so on and so forth
not that they're terrible i'm not saying
like oh this is game so terrible i'm not
going in
i'm just saying that to me they keep
showing me
what they're capable of and i think at
the end of the day
um they're not they they're not the 365
24
7 game that we're used to just living in
yeah right yeah now we do things we get
in we get out we do something else
so at the end of the day um yeah
i think that i i i wouldn't mind uh
he partnered with microsoft i'm not an
acquisition right
like you're you're you're thinking maybe
bringing a partner yeah
to go back to the destiny that
people want to live in right if current
that's what i'm trying to tell people
now
under its current status if you're
trying to just do destiny
like god bless you but you're super
amazing you're able to do all these
different things
you you're able to still engage your
community with content same thing with
the boxes of
these things but at the same time
there's people who they just
can't they're not they're unable because
the game is not how it used to be right
yeah they want to live in it they want
to make content 24 7 they're unable to
and i'm trying to tell those people and
it's current status it's just
not sustainable to be a content creator
that way unless you're creative as
you are you know what i'm saying yeah so
that makes sense you got to play other
games you know what i'm saying
for those guys those guys got to play
other games so that's a really good
point
yeah so for me you know i'm cool
i understand what's going on i can play
other games i can do everything but
for that guy so that's the only reason
why i want the acquisition so they have
the most
support studios they have the resources
to have the financial backing
and microsoft wouldn't bother them you
know i'm saying microsoft were their
acquisition like they
they are still gonna destiny would still
be multiplied it wouldn't go
exclusive to what i'm saying now the new
iep
that's a different story if that matter
or whatever it is that would be
different
you know what i'm saying but yeah that
that's that's what i feel i i
i want the big thing i want them and
that makes sense
the best content came with you know
either activision vicarious visions or
you know
yeah yeah all of them yeah yeah foreign
yeah that makes sense
yeah so that's what i got what you got
you oh me
see if i can think straight for a minute
oh yeah no i mean for me
you guys both kind of touched on pieces
i want loot to matter more
uh i mean datto's even said he's like
why you know why am i going after all of
these things for
another scout rifle another auto auto
rifle
you know the perks and stuff like that
one of my big ones is armor you
literally see a game like outriders
having armor sets
set bonuses for different classes like
class specific strike specific set
bonuses
there's a lot you can do to give some
variety to the grinds
and it feels like they haven't they
dabbled one season with drifter
with set bonuses oh that's true yeah
that's just true
and then they still thought that was a
trend remember we thought that was gonna
be a trend
i mean i wish that was like it was a
start i was like all right keep it going
not there either and it's just been
i mean as you said like this could be
one of those building years this could
be whatever it is like my eyes
unless they prove otherwise my eyes are
looking
out to witch queen because the
in-between seasons
right depending on what happens this
coming like hunt was small beyond light
pretty good
uh you know whatever comes in season of
the reacted we'll have to see but it's
like they've said like
do you expect an opulence a sundial
i don't know i was like they've just got
to prove it i want to i'm going to be
here for the whole story at this point
like crow
zavo wrath sabathune i want to see this
all the way to the end three years from
now whatever how many years they do the
story
i'm excited about the story i just want
to know what's going to as you guys say
keep me compelled to keep playing the
game
i'm at one of my lowest season ranks
this year and i'm like 114. i hit 100.
done some activities but i'm fairly low
why
do you know seasonal challenges if it's
more gambit strikes and crucible and
those playlists look exactly like they
do right now or maybe two more strikes
and that's it
like what else is going to keep me
compelled so that's kind of where i'm at
you guys have heard my armor 3.0 very
big question to wonder what that's going
to be
but again i still don't know so no
that's a good point too i didn't even
think about that gambit prime set that
was a step in the right direction i
think the thing that probably
skewed it and for bungie is they
probably got the negative
reaction just because it was gambit yeah
and thought the whole
idea was was bad when it when you know
it might have even just been
people don't enjoy a certain activity
but the the idea of the armor piece
i think was a step in the right
direction i do agree with that
yeah the weird thing like a grind this
armor in here that works in this other
thing
doesn't even make you better like it was
a very disjointed implementation of
armor sets
yeah and if you could ask anybody it's
like hey was armor sets bad or was it
because they were part of drifter and
gambit it's option b every time people
would love to see armor set so it's like
if they
ask the community they could be like hey
these are a thing maybe they don't know
how to balance them
but there's some small tweaks you could
give that could make you a little better
so
that's all mine are i know we got to
wrap this thing up for cognito so i
don't want to dwell on this one too long
so i'm gonna miss it cook they'll be
saying we go we gotta get in yeah he's
like
got away here so we gotta make sure he
can get to what he needs to get to
let this thing wrap up right now cb gray
the floor is yours
where can people find you where all of
the places it sounds like
what do you got going on anything to
look forward to any ideas for your next
song
pretty much the floor is yours let him
know where to find her what you got
doing um
oh well youtube uh cb grade
twitch cb gray um the big two for
streaming uh we stream every day for the
most part at least you know
six days a week try to um both platforms
youtube first twitch after
um in terms of new stuff at least in
terms of song that you mentioned uh
probably witch queen again try to see if
we can come up with something similar
uh for that fall time period again um
i'll set up that in terms of new stuff
you know for me yes uh it's gonna be the
same old same old we're gonna keep
you know helping out where we can keep
laughing keep having fun and you know
just keep kind of
running around in circles and just
acting a fool so
that that's the big thing for me um but
instead of giving the floor to me also
like i want to give big shout out to
y'all again too man it's been
a lot of fun you know it always is i
mean i knew it was gonna be but man it's
just we always figured out a way to just
make it
it just it just takes turns like you
just i just wouldn't expect it to turn
but um
seriously i appreciate all the love
you'll be showing um both of these two
they're both amazing and um they're
really the ones that
i mean they just they deserve a whole
lot of praise like i said the beginning
134 episodes i had to go back i looked i
was like
my eyes are like man i really see that
134
that's a whole lot of times to do
anything like i mean doing anything 134
times
is like really really impressive and the
amount of coordination it takes to
you know reach out to people and you
know uh and to put all this together
and to have this this format and topics
to talk about and
on top of the jobs they balance and the
family they balance in the streams they
balance too because
he does a lot of streams over here on
twitch and on youtube i've been seeing
them e
he's been on youtube too oh yeah laura
cognito is holding it down the youtube
front as well they got
crazy crazy podcasts on the weekend that
i always watch while i'm working
they got a lot going on they still put
on every single week and that's that's
really impressive and there's deserves a
lot more praise than
anything y'all are showing me um so with
that with that being said like
definitely um yeah just keep showing
them love because they're they're
amazing and i appreciate all the love
that y'all showed me today i mean it
means a lot like thank you for bringing
me on
always it's always a pleasure i like
laughing too you know laughing
we do a lot of laughing man
as long as i i'm like as long as we're
laughing you know i'm good man
absolutely man yeah it's always a fun
man always a pleasure to have you on
once
it makes me realize how much i miss you
yeah
and maybe we can uh i don't know i want
to jump in the gun but you know
we'll see what what's what before which
queen and maybe we can you know
yeah see what's wrong yeah yeah yeah
sure for sure oh dude you are always
welcome back you know that for sure you
know that
i appreciate it but yeah no but thank
you guys for the time i mean it's it's
it flew by i can't believe it's already
10. i was like damn
but i'll uh leave y'all with the final
question too though what what's the
biggest thing y'all
are um like got going on for the future
i'll say podcast and individually
you know i'ma flip the script on y'all
one more tip for both of you
floors yours but i think what i got
going on i mean i can tell you what uh
i have a podcast going on this sunday
yeah yeah yeah for me like i said again
yeah salute to ucb this was a tremendous
episode i had so much fun um for me you
already know look at me on twitter
i don't know podcast on sunday we're
gonna have a guest on my man gaz from
game on daily they're really cool
out in london and they've been really
killing it as a content creator
and um just like almost like a news
aggregate as well as a digital foundry
thing where they're kind of breaking
down the technical aspects of games
and uh yeah man we got we got cool more
guests playing i can't explore all over
what jigsaw
but some big guests you know for the
rest of the year and it's just really
cool to see
you know people wanting to come on like
that's the new thing like people are
like yo
well when you're gonna get me i'm not
used to that i'm like i'm used to
begging
people to like yo people like yo you
haven't had me on
yeah he hasn't been backward in a while
yeah
i gotta get e-back on you know what i'm
saying so um yeah man just just salute
to the community and the main thing you
know like you saw the couple whatever
you know lords of gaming.net you know i
really am
super proud of the website it's by the
gamers you know these guys
choose to write for us and a very
diverse community and i just love it
it's just a passion project that's
growing
we like to celebrate those guys and um
it's just been cool to see people share
the articles and stuff like
that so salute thank you for that and uh
i'll leave the rest the email that's
right y'all doing a great job too with
that too
just by my dad oh yeah yeah salute
for me you guys kicked my butt but you
know
i'm i'm a little tired but you guys know
how to find me
uh it's on youtube twitch twitter
ibantus
pretty much everywhere i can be
streaming on now youtube and twitch
uh playing other games i will work on
trying to get a screen schedule up on
wednesday for at least a couple days to
commit but you guys
know i do sometimes just kick the stream
on other times so make sure you guys do
those follows and alerts
and honestly always to the scholar and
the gentleman that is both my co-host
and very lucky to call my friend cognito
sir thank you very much for
as we said 134. many many more to go to
see how long this thing goes
and sir cb gray
yes sir i appreciate you gracing us with
your tinfoil hat
and your positivity you've always got
you always exude like goodness
and i think that's one of those things
that is so infectious about you
um and honestly like people in your
community are
fantastic chat has been awesome tonight
so we thank you for so much seriously
it's been it's been a blast yeah i know
we'll all
completely agree we're like all in terms
of all of our communities absolutely
nothing without show so i mean
it's like all the credit to all of y'all
for even like you know
um having us in the places that we are
and so yeah
i know i'm grateful i know they are we
all appreciate you so seriously
much love much
these guys you know showing up and
interacting and making us laugh
and just doing fun stuff and the
interaction
you can't beat that like it really means
a lot to have all the communities
all our communities really you know
support us in the way they do and show
us the love that we do we wouldn't be
there with
anything without them so yeah absolutely
cb i agree
well for this episode guys we are going
to wrap it up so cognito can run
um this has been episode 134 we are
going to go raid bearded luke he's
actually our guest
next week he is streaming right now so
send some love over to him
when you guys raid go over there explode
his channel send some love likes follows
to him
he will be on the show next week i think
he's going to be an am show if i
remember correctly but
okay follow follow the the last word pod
twitter you guys will get notifications
of that
and for this episode today we are going
to wrap this thing up so for episode 134
of january 29th thank you all very much
it has been the last